Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. I am the great traitor. There must be no other. Anyone who even thinks about deserting this mission will be cut up into 98 pieces. Whoever takes one grain of corn or one drop of water more than his ration will be locked up for 155 years. If I, Aguirre, want the birds to drop dead from the trees, then the birds will drop dead from the trees. I am the wrath of God. The earth I pass will see me and tremble. Whoever follows me on
感谢收听《历史的 Rest》（The Rest is History）。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先收听节目系列，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我是伟大的叛徒。绝不能有第二个。任何胆敢萌生背叛这次任务念头的人，都会被砍成98块。谁要是多拿了一粒玉米或多喝了一滴超出定量份额的水，就会被关押155年。如果我，阿基雷，想让树上的鸟儿当场毙命，树上的鸟儿就会当场毙命。我是上帝的愤怒。我所过之处，大地都将为之战栗。任何跟随我顺着
the river will win untold riches. We will control all of New Spain and we will stage history as others stage plays. I, the wrath of God, will marry my own daughter and this I have found the purest dynasty ever known to man. Together we will rule the whole of this continent. The Wrath of God! So that was Klaus Kinski, the great German actor, as Lope de Aguirre in the film Aguirre, The Wrath of God, which was made in 1972, directed by Funster Werner Herzog and loosely based on, I mean, one of the most remarkable episodes of European exploration in history, a 16th century Spanish band of conquistadors venturing into the Amazon rainforest in search of El Dorado and it doesn't end well.
河水前进的人，都将赢得难以计数的财富。我们将控制整个新西班牙，我们将像别人排演戏剧一样导演历史。我，上帝的愤怒，将娶我自己的亲生女儿，这是我为人类所开创的最纯正的王朝。我们将共同统治这整块大陆。上帝的愤怒！刚才那是克劳斯·金斯基，伟大的德国演员，在1972年上映的电影《阿基雷，上帝的愤怒》中饰演洛佩·德·阿基雷。这部电影由鬼才导演维尔纳·赫尔佐格执导，大致取材于——我是说，取材于欧洲探险史上最奇特的插曲之一：16世纪的一支西班牙征服者小分队冒险深入亚马逊雨林寻找黄金国，而结局并不美妙。
And it's one of the maddest films ever made, partly because of course, the conquistadors speak in German and we know that they would have spoken in English, obviously. But also Dominic, I guess because it ranks alongside Francis Ford Coppola's attempt to finish Apocalypse Now as a kind of cinematic folly de grandeur, doesn't it? It does indeed. Because they go into the jungle and it's all terrible and Herzog tries to kill Kinsky. Kinsky's going mad he's got his great bulging eyeballs. Yeah. The making of the film is carnage. It is. And it's holding a mirror up to the carnage of the original 16th century expedition.
这也是拍过的最疯狂的电影之一，部分原因当然是，那些征服者说的是德语，而我们知道他们本来应该说英语的，显而易见。但多米尼克，我想这也是因为它与弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉试图完成《现代启示录》的努力一样，位列某种宏大电影荒诞之作，对吧？的确如此。因为他们走进了丛林，一切都糟透了，赫尔佐格还试图杀死金斯基。金斯基发疯了，瞪着他那双大突眼。是的。这部电影的拍摄过程简直是一场大屠杀。确实如此。而这也恰好映照了16世纪初次远征的那场屠杀。
Exactly it's very like Apocalypse Now in that sense so they shot it in the early 70s as you say. They shot it on location in the Peruvian Amazon and Herzog at one point threatened to shoot Kinski, his lead actor, and then turn the gun on himself. And that's sort of been reported as he was basically forcing Kinski to film scenes at gunpoint, which I think is a slight exaggeration, but the filming of it was demented. But that actually, of course, reflected the subject matter, which is this, as you say, this expedition that's very, very heart of darkness, actually, the 16th century expedition. It's about European colonizers, colonialists, conquistadors in Heart of Darkness, which we did a podcast on a few weeks ago. You know, they go up the Congo, Joseph Conrad is narrator Marlowe goes up the Congo.
没错，从这个意义上说，它非常类似于《现代启示录》，所以他们在70年代初拍摄了这部电影，正如你所说。他们是在秘鲁亚马逊河实地拍摄的，赫尔佐格甚至一度威胁要枪杀他的男主角金斯基，然后再把枪口对准自己。这在某种程度上被报道为他基本上是在枪口下逼迫金斯基拍摄场景，我认为这有点夸张，但这部电影的拍摄过程确实极其疯狂。不过，这当然也反映了它的主题——正如你所说，这是一次非常深入黑暗之心的远征，实际上是16世纪的远征。它讲的是欧洲殖民者、殖民主义者、征服者进入黑暗之心的故事，我们几周前刚为此做过一期播客。你知道，他们逆刚果河而上，约瑟夫·康拉德笔下的叙述者马洛就逆刚果河而上。
He's in search of this guy, Kurtz, who's lost his mind. Marlowe goes up the Congo he's in search of this guy Kurtz who's lost his mind well in this story it's the people who are going up the river who lose their minds and particularly this bloke Aguirre who I think it's fair to say is one of the strangest and most unsettling characters we've ever done on on this podcast it's really interesting the books about him are often written by some of them are by professional historians but one of the best for example is by a guy called Robert Silverberg who's actually a science fiction writer. Yeah he did so all those books with kind of giant spaceships. Yeah. And he wrote an
他在寻找这个精神失常的家伙库尔茨。马洛逆刚果河而上，他在寻找这个精神失常的家伙库尔茨。而在个故事里，是逆流而上的人们失去了理智，特别是这个叫阿基雷的家伙。我认为公平地说，他是我们在这个播客里讲过的最奇怪、最让人不安的人物之一。这真的很有趣，关于他的书有些是由专业历史学家写的，但其中最好的一本是由一个叫罗伯特·西尔维伯格的人写的，他其实是一位科幻小说家。对，他写过所有那些带有巨型飞船的书。对。他写了一
absolutely brilliant book called The Golden Dream a history of quests for El Dorado like very scrupulously researched very serious book and he describes Aguirre in this book he he says is the single most villainous figure in the annals of the Spanish conquest which is you know it's quite a high bar to clear and then there's the great historian of the Amazon John Hemming who wrote a brilliant book about the fall of the Incas and he says of a gear a simply cruel psychopathic a man of unmitigated evil yes the people are going to enjoy this. Yeah. Yeah, it's always good to have a character like that on the podcast.
本绝对精彩的书叫《黄金梦想：对黄金国寻宝历程的历史》，这是一本经过极其严谨考证、非常严肃的书。他在书中这样描述阿基雷，他说他是西班牙征服史册中绝无仅有的最十恶不赦的人物——你知道，这个标准可以说是相当高了。然后还有亚马逊的伟大历史学家约翰·海明，他写过一本关于印加帝国灭亡的精彩著作，他对阿基雷的评价很简单：残忍、变态，一个彻头彻尾的纯粹恶魔。是的，听众们会喜欢这一期的。是的。是的，播客里总归需要一个这样的人物。
I mean, it is very Heart of Darkness, so very reminiscent of the series we just did on the Congo. But we've also just done an episode on Dr. John Dee, Elizabeth I's kind of great magus. And his great ambition is to track down secrets that will unleash untold wealth. Right. And the whole El Dorado quest. Yes. Sense that there is a golden ruler, a golden city lost somewhere in the jungle, and that if only you can find it, then you will be unspeakably rich. This also is part of the Aguirre story. So it's a kind of fusion of the two, isn't it? It's absolutely part of the Aguirre story. And yet the mad thing about it is there's pretty much only one person in this story
我的意思是，这非常像《黑暗之心》，让人十分怀念我们刚刚制作的关于刚果的系列节目。但我们最近也刚做了一集关于约翰·迪博士的节目，他是伊丽莎白一世麾下的伟大魔法师。他最大的野心就是搜寻能够释放无数财富的秘密。没错。而整个寻找黄金国的历程也是如此。是的。人们觉得在丛林深处的某个地方，隐藏着一个金色的统治者、一座黄金之城，只要你能找到它，你就会拥有不可思议的财富。这也是阿基雷故事的一部分。所以这可以说是两者的融合，对吧？这绝对是阿基雷故事的一部分。然而最疯狂的是，这个故事里几乎只有一个人
who thinks that El Dorado is a complete myth and a nonsense. And that's Aguirre. There's an argument possibly he's the only sane man on the expedition. Isn't there some historian who says that he's the only man in history to look for El Dorado who didn't want to find it? Exactly. Exactly. Well, we'll come to that that. In fact he tries to dissuade other people from trying to find it. So let's give everybody a bit of context because there would be lots of people who are not familiar with this story at all. So we're in the Spanish Empire in the late 1550s, so that means the Aztecs and the Incas
认为黄金国纯属神话和无稽之谈。那就是阿基雷。有一种观点甚至认为他是这次远征中唯一一个神智清醒的人。难道没有哪个历史学家说过他是历史上唯一一个寻找黄金国却不想找到它的人吗？完全正确。完全正确。好吧，我们待会儿会讲到这一点。事实上，他曾试图劝阻其他人不要去寻找它。所以让我们给听众们提供一点背景信息，因为有很多人对这个故事完全不熟悉。现在我们身处16世纪50年代末的西班牙帝国，这意味着阿兹特克人和印加人
have been conquered a generation ago, loads of silver is flying back to Europe from Mexico and Peru, but if in your mind you're thinking okay well South America has been conquered by Spain, the story is over. That's not right at all. Spanish rule is very fragile and it's really just confined to the coasts. And Spain itself, although it's very rich and powerful, it's in a kind of world of trouble. So the emperor Charles V abdicated in 1556 and Spain and its empire passed to his son Philip II. He appears to be very rich and powerful but he inherits a great mess. There's huge inflation thanks to all of the silver. Spain has been fighting all these wars in Italy and the Holy Roman Empire. He has to default on Spain's loans straight away. He's got no money.
在几十年前就已经被征服，大量的白银从墨西哥和秘鲁源源不断地运回欧洲；但如果你脑子里觉得，好吧，既然南美洲已经被西班牙征服，故事就此结束了，那就大错特错了。西班牙的统治非常脆弱，实际上仅限于沿海地区。而且西班牙本身，尽管十分富裕强大，却正处于一片水深火热之中。因此，查理五世皇帝于1556年退位，西班牙及其帝国传给了他的儿子腓力二世。他看起来似乎很富有、很强大，但他继承却是一个巨大的烂摊子。由于大量的白银涌入，恶性通货膨胀严重。西班牙一直在意大利和神圣罗马帝国参与所有这些战争。他不得不立即宣布西班牙的贷款违约。他根本没钱。
He's struggling to raise taxes in Spain itself and the obvious place to look is the New World. Let's get more gold and silver from the New World. But the problem is that his authority, and this is going to be really important to explain the political context to this story, his royal authority is very weak in the Spanish colonies. So in Peru for example, you know the Incas have as it were fallen, but there are still only about 4,000 European Spaniards in Peru and Lima and whatnot, and they are fighting these endless civil wars and there are little rebellions and feuds and things and in
他在西班牙本土筹集税收举步维艰，而显而易见的目标就是新世界。让我们从新世界获取更多的黄金和白银。但问题是，他的权威——这对于解释这个故事的政治背景至关重要——他在西班牙殖民地的王权非常微弱。例如，在秘鲁，印加人可以说已经倒台了，但秘鲁、利马及其他地方的欧洲西班牙人总共也只有大约4000人，他们正在进行这些没完没了的内战，还有大大小小的叛乱和世仇。而在
1556 a new viceroy called the Marcus of Canete arrived in Lima from Spain and Dominic when he arrives in Lima does he find the lilting of a Spanish guitar he doesn't actually Tom he hears the sound of screams and chaos. Because law and order have slightly broken down in Lima. This is not the world of Pannington Bear, it's this. It's a much darker world. The place is in chaos. There are unemployed soldiers and ruffians everywhere,
1556年，一位名叫卡涅特侯爵的新总督从西班牙抵达利马。多米尼克，当他抵达利马时，他听到的是西班牙吉他悠扬的弹奏声吗？汤姆，其实并没有，他听到的是尖叫声和混乱的声音。因为利马的法律和秩序已经略微崩塌了。这里可不是帕丁顿熊的世界，而是这里。这是一个黑暗得多的世界。这个地方陷入了混乱。到处都是失业的士兵和地痞流氓，
total sort of feuds and vendettas. And he has to try to sort this out. You know, he wants to find money to impress Philip II. And you can see why this scenario would appeal to a science fiction writer. Yeah. It's a kind of staple, isn't it? The new colony on a distant planet. Yeah.
各种家族宿怨和寻仇不断。他不得不设法整顿这一切。你知道，他想找到资金来在腓力二世面前留下好印象。你能看出为什么这种剧本会吸引科幻作家了。是的。这是一种经典的设定，对吧？遥远星球上的新殖民地。是的。
Full of gun runners and smugglers and desperados. That's exactly what it is. I think we should assume that almost everybody in this story, who we mentioned at this point almost, has an enormous scar running from their eyebrow right down to their chin or something. A weapon with a personal nickname. Exactly. Yeah.
到处都是走私枪支的人、走私犯和亡命之徒。完全就是这样。我认为我们应该假设这个故事中的几乎每个人——我们提到的几乎所有人——脸上都有一道从眉毛一直延伸到下巴的巨大伤疤之类的。手里拿着一件有个人绰号的武器。绝对的。是的。
Gutsplitter. Yeah. The widow weeper or something of that kind. Anyway, at about this point, when the Marcus of Cignete arrives in Lima, an Amazonian Indian chieftain arrives in Peru from the east. And it's very like the sort of barbarians on the periphery of the Roman Empire. There are all kinds of movements of people who are pushing other people because of the arrival of the Europeans.
开膛手。是的。寡妇哭号者诸如此类的东西。不管怎样，就在卡涅特侯爵抵达利马的这个时候，一位亚马逊印第安部落酋长从东部来到了秘鲁。这非常像罗马帝国边缘地带的那些蛮族。由于欧洲人的到来，各种各样的人口迁徙都在挤压着其他人。
So it's caused kind of chaos among the tribes. And this bloke is taken, the leader of this tribe is taken to see the Spanish authorities and he says, we've traveled a long way, we've traveled along the Amazon and I have seen lands rich in gold and the Marcus of Kenyette's eye, you know, he raises his eyebrows to this. Yeah, he's so brilliant. And this tallies with two things that people in the two great colonial cities of the western side of the continent, which are Lima and Quito now in Ecuador, this tallies with two
因此，这在各个部族中引发了一种混乱。这个人被带去面见西班牙当局，这个部落的领袖说，我们走了很远的路，我们沿着亚马逊河一路走来，我看到了盛产黄金的土地。卡涅特侯爵的眼睛——你知道，他为此挑了挑眉毛。是的，他太棒了。这与大陆西部两大殖民城市（即现在的利马和厄瓜多尔的基多）的人们所相信的两件事不谋而合。首先，大约10年前，一个名叫弗朗西斯科·德·奥雷亚纳的人领导了历史上最伟大的探险之一，即欧洲人对亚马逊河全长的第一次远征。他航行了4000英里。而奥雷亚纳报告说，他看到了非常巨大、非常富裕的定居点，那里的人们住在城镇里，穿着精美的织物衣服，有着精湛的制陶工艺，还有数不清的白银。几个世纪以来，人们一直认为这全都是无稽之谈，只是个寓言；但实际上，现在亚马逊历史学家的主流趋势是认为，亚马逊
things that they believe. First of all, 10 years or so earlier, a man called Francisco de Oriana had led one of the great expeditions in all history, the first European expedition on the whole length of the Amazon. And he had traveled for 4,000 miles. And he, Oriana, reported that he had seen very large, very rich settlements, people who lived in towns, people who wore fine woven clothes with great pottery and loads and loads of silver. And for centuries people have assumed since then that this was all nonsense and just a fable but actually now the trend among historians of Amazonia is to say actually Amazonia
其实可能比我们想象的更加发达，那里的人口更多，也更加成熟。从长远来看，他们中的很多人最终都被疾病等原因消灭了，所以他们一直以来都被轻视，但考古学家现在认为这里面有很大的真相。其次，在利马和基多，人们一直在交换关于这个叫做黄金国的地方的故事。这似乎最初是源于对西班牙人在大陆另一侧（哥伦比亚）活动的一种非常失真、夸大和混乱的报告。
probably was more built up than we think and there were more people there and they were more sophisticated and they're all killed in the long run, a lot of them by disease and things, so they've been discounted ever since, but archaeologists now think there was a lot of truth in this. And then the second thing is that in Lima and Quito, people have been swapping stories about this place called El Dorado, and this seems to have originated as a very garbled and exaggerated and confused report of what the Spanish were doing on the other side of the continent in Colombia,
在那里，他们正在征服一个叫做穆伊斯卡的民族。这些穆伊斯卡人相当富有，这个故事基本上被添油加醋、面目全非地传成了一个土地富饶的传说：那里的国王会把金粉涂满全身，每年在宗教仪式上把大量的黄金扔进湖里，到处都是黄金，还有一个装满黄金的湖泊，诸如此类的事情。因为黄金国字面意思就是金人，对吧？金光闪闪的人。完全正确。所以无论如何，卡涅特侯爵抵达了利马，周围流传着各种各样的谣言，亚马逊河里有各种未知的事物，谁知道呢？而他灵机一动——这真的很聪明：
where they were conquering a people called the Muisca. And these Muisca were quite rich, and this basically became embellished and garbled into a story of a land so rich that the king could sort of paint himself in gold dust, throw a load of gold into the lake every year in a religious ritual and there's gold everywhere and there's a lake full of gold and all of this kind of business. Because El Dorado is literally the golden man isn't it? The golden one. Exactly. So the Marcus de Canete anyway, he arrives in Lima and there's all of these different rumors hanging around, all the stuff out there in the Amazon, who knows, and his great brainwave is, and it's really smart,
“我可以通过对这帮脸上带着伤疤的无赖们说：‘小伙子们，你们为什么不去进行一次大规模的远征去寻找黄金国呢？’来摆脱他们。”因为如果他们真的找到了，他就会成为拯救西班牙财政的人。他可以把所有的黄金运回给腓力二世，那就太棒了。如果他们没找到，他们就会死。绝妙。太妙了。他把他们甩掉了。这是一举两得。因此，为了指挥这次远征，他任命了一个名叫佩德罗·德·苏阿的人，他是一名来自潘普洛纳纳瓦尔的骑士。大家都说他非常勇敢、非常豪爽、非常固执己见。
I'll get rid of all these ne'er-do-wells with their scars by saying to them, lads, why don't you go off on a massive expedition to go and find El Dorado? Because if they do find it, he'll be the man who saved Spain's finances. He can send all the gold back to Philip II, and that's great. If they don't find it, and they'll die. Brilliant. Brilliant. He's rid of them. It's win-win. So to command the expedition, he appoints a fellow called Pedro de Asura, who is a knight from Navarre, from Pamplona. Everyone says he's very brave, he's very gallant, he's very headstrong.
他其实并不是毫无经验。他已经在新格拉纳达（也就是哥伦比亚）服役了大约10年。他以前已经参加过几次寻找黄金国的远征。虽然没有什么实质收获。但他绝不是个全无头脑的笨蛋。于是他被任命领导这次远征。有人对他说：“当你征服阿马瓜和黄金国省份时，你将作为总督统治那里。”而他想，这太棒了，因为这正是征服者们梦寐以求的。他们想要一块领地，想要一个官方
He's actually not without experience. He has been serving in New Granada, which is Colombia, for about 10 years. He's already gone on some El Dorado expeditions. No joy really. But he's not a complete idiot. So he is appointed to lead the expedition. He is told when you conquer the province of Amagwa and Dorado you will rule it as governor. And he thinks, well brilliant, because this is of course what conquistadors want. They want a slice of territory and they want an official
任命，这样他们就能从中捞钱。这一切的目的全在于此。科尔萨斯、皮萨罗以及所有人都是如此。因此，在接下来的大约一年时间里，苏阿组建了他的队伍，按当时的标准拉起了一支非常非常庞大的远征军：大约有400名西班牙人和数千名秘鲁印第安人（现在人们大概会称他们为秘鲁原住民），这是未来两个世纪进入亚马逊地区的规模最大的欧洲军队。我必须说，这支远征军中的大多数人并不是那种你会选择一起去度假的人。他们有点像是黑帮分子、雇佣兵、刑满释放人员。公平地说，他们都是狠角色，汤姆。然后他们开始在亚马逊河边缘建造各种木筏和双桅轻帆船，准备用来驶入那片河网。这有点像把意大利西部片搬到了热带雨林里。
appointment so that they can make money out of it. That's what all this is about. It's what Cortez, Pizarro, all of these people. So Ossua, over the next year or so, he gathers his team, he gets a very very large expedition by the standards of the day, about 400 Spaniards and thousands of Peruvian Indians, native Peruvians I suppose people might call them now, and it's the largest European force for the next two centuries to enter Amazonia. I have to say most of the people on this expedition are not people with whom one would choose to go on holiday. They're kind of gangsters, mercenaries, ex-cons. They're hard men, I think it's fair to say, Tom. And they start building all these rafts and brigantines on the edge of Amazonia that they will use to go into the kind of river network. It's kind of a spaghetti western only in a jungle.
完全没错，这是一部意大利西部片。接下来我们要制作一些关于哈拉尔德·哈德拉达进入罗斯人土地的节目，我觉得这里面带有轻微的维京元素——那种有点吓人的硬汉，他们对脸上纹身这种事绝对不会陌生。是的，他们冒险深入，寻找黄金，如果能顺便大开杀戒就更好了。不过胡子拉碴倒是真的，完全是的。我觉得这可以说是一个稍微爱出汗的版本。无论如何，在1560年夏天，在动身之前，苏阿收到了一封朋友的信。朋友在信中对他说：“听着，你犯了
Exactly it's a spaghetti western or so we're going to be doing some episodes about Harold Hard Roger going into the lands of the Rus and I think there's a slight Viking element to this kind of slightly terrifying men who would be no strangers to a facial tattoo. Yeah kind of venturing in search of gold and hopefully some slaughter a lot of stubble though exactly yeah this is a slightly sweatier version I think it's probably fair to say anyway in the summer of 1560 before he sets off a sewer gets a letter from a friend and the friend says to him look you're
两个可怕的错误。错误一：你带上了你的情妇多尼娅·伊内斯·德·阿蒂恩萨。请告诉我她长得极其丑陋！请告诉我她绝对不是美若天仙，汤姆！那样多么豪爽。这为了我们好，也为了远征队的利益。所以不，据说她是整个秘鲁最美丽的女人。这太疯狂了，简直是灾难！400个亡命之徒和一个女人。”是的，她是一个年轻的寡妇。她很可能是混血儿或梅斯蒂索人。事后有大约四到五份目击者记录流传下来。在这个问题上，它们的说法却令人沮丧地不一致。有些人说她是一个名节无可指责的女人。另一些人则说她在感情上有点随便。所以很难知道
making two dreadful mistakes mistake number one you are taking your mistress. What donya in yes to atienza? Please tell me she is incredibly ugly Please tell me she's not absolutely gorgeous Tom so gallant It's for our own good and for the good of the expedition So no, she said to be the most beautiful woman in all of Peru that is mad disastrous 400 desperado's and one woman Yeah, so she's a young widow. She's probably mixed race or mestizo. There are like four or five eyewitness accounts written after the event. On this issue they're frustratingly inconsistent. So some say she's a woman of unimpeachable honor. Others say she's a little bit free with her affections. So it's hard to know
真相到底是什么，汤姆。我想听众们可以自己下定论。总之，苏阿的朋友说：“你带她去简直是疯了。不会有好结果的。”——请允许我引用原话——“随之而来的邪恶将比你所能想象的还要巨大。”我有一种感觉，他们说得没错。是的。嗯，尤其是因为这位朋友还说：“你带的不只是相当糟糕的坏人，你带的一些人简直是坏透了。”他说，最坏的一个人叫洛佩·德·阿基雷。所以我们从阿基雷后来写给腓力二世的一封信中得知——我们待会儿会谈到这封信——阿基雷于1510年出生在巴斯克地区。他在20岁出头时来到秘鲁。他曾当过驯马师和打手。这真是个吓人的履历，
the truth there Tom. I think you listeners just make up their own minds. Anyway, a Suez Mate says, you are mad to take her with you. Nothing good will So it's hard to know the truth there Tom. I think you'd be listeners just make up their own minds Anyway, a Sue's mate says you are mad to take her with you Nothing good will come of it and I quote greater evils will follow than you can possibly suppose and I have a sense They're not right. Yes. Well, especially as the friend also says you're not just taking quite bad men Some of the men you're taking are unbelievably bad men and he says the worst is a man called Lope de Aguirre. So we know from a letter that Aguirre later wrote to Philip II, which we shall come on to. Aguirre had been born in 1510 in the Basque country. He'd come to Peru in his early 20s. He'd worked as a horse breaker and a general enforcer. That's a terrifying TV,
对吧？有一份精彩的记录，是根据方济各会修士弗雷·西蒙的其他记录整理出来的。西蒙这样评价阿基雷：“他身材矮小，骨瘦如柴，长相丑陋，面容瘦小，留着黑胡子，眼神像鹰一样锐利，看人时目光严厉，尤其是生气的时候。”所以他总体上是一个有点让人不安的存在。是的。所有的编年史家都一致认为他话很多，说话粗鲁，脾气极其暴躁，而且极其记仇。当你把这放在南美洲西班牙征服的背景下时，
isn't it? And there's a wonderful account based on other accounts by a Franciscan monk with Fré Simon and Simon said of Aguirre He was of short stature and sparely made ill featured the face small and lean beard black The eyes like a hawk and when he looked he fixed his eyes sternly particularly when angry So he's generally a slightly Unsettling presence. Yeah. All the chroniclers agree that he talks a lot. He's very roughly spoken. He's incredibly bad tempered and he's incredibly vengeful. And when you think this is in the context
人们现在还说这家伙（你知道的）已经越界了，这就非常令人不安了。他总是被逐出城镇，他真的是个意大利西部片里的角色。正如弗雷·西蒙所说，他有点跛。我一直认为这对于征服者来说是一个不祥的征兆，因为他的腿曾中过枪。弗雷·西蒙说他被一个省驱逐到另一个省，人称“疯子阿基雷”（Aguirre el Loco）。
of the Spanish Conquest of South America. Yeah. And people are saying now this bloke, you know, he's crossed the line That's very disturbing. So he's always being kicked out of towns He really is a spaghetti western character and as phrase simon says he has a limp Which I always think is an unsettling sign in the conquistador because he's been shot in the leg phrase simon says he was driven from one province to another and was known as Aguirre el Loco, the madman. Right.
所以他加入了这次远征。还有一件事，他把他的女儿也带来了。所以他的女儿——他和一个印第安女人有一个女儿，女儿名叫埃尔维拉。她多大？13岁。13岁。哦，所以他是带她去上学的？嗯，她一直跟他旅行，据说他对她极其疼爱。
So he's signed up to this expedition. And the other thing is he's brought with him his daughter. So his daughter, he had a daughter with an Indian woman and his daughter is called Elvira. And how old is she? 13. 13 years old. Oh, so he's taking her to school. Well, she always travels with him and apparently he is completely devoted to her.
就像这是他真正的软肋一样。你知道的，他对埃尔维拉非常认真。但是，如果有谁听了觉得“你们怎么把孩子带离学校了”，千万别学。绝对不要。在英国是要罚款的吧？我认为这是一个有益的警告，提醒人们可能会发生什么，什么地方会出错。
Like this is his real soft spot. Right. You know, he takes Elvira very seriously. But, I mean, should anyone be listening and think you've taken their children out of school? Don't. Just don't do it. You have to pay a fine, don't you, in England? This is a salutary warning, I think, of what could happen, what could go wrong.
千万不要带着一群无赖去亚马逊。不。远征队的指挥官佩德罗·德·苏阿完全无视了这封信，这简直是疯了。1560年9月26日，他带着他的远征军出发，驶入亚马逊河的支流。从一开始，不出所料，事情就开始出岔子了。他们建造了所有这些船只，但船体出现了严重的漏水，他不得不把除了其中一艘之外的所有船都抛弃在后面。什么，所以他正准备出发，结果造了这么多船，然后却一艘都带不走？除了留下一艘？他能带走一艘双桅轻帆船，然后就是大量的木筏。他为什么不等等把它们修好呢？因为那要花太长时间！而且你知道的，因为大家已经很不耐烦了。说实话，我已经删掉了很多他们之间的争吵。好吧。
Certainly don't go to the Amazon with a group of ne'er-do-wells. No. Pedro de Assur, the commander of the expedition, completely ignores this letter, which is madness. And on the 26th of September 1560 he sets off with his expedition into the tributaries of the Amazon. And right from the start, surprise surprise, things start to go wrong. They've built all these ships but there are massive leaks on them and he has to leave all but one of them behind. What, so he's setting off and he's got all these ships built and then he can't take any
他们之间已经有很多争吵了。我有了一种非常不祥的预感。好吧。于是他们全都挤进这些木筏里，但苏阿坚持要留出一个船舱专门给自己和多尼娅·伊内斯，这让远征队的其他成员非常不满。正如弗雷·西蒙所说：“人们情绪低落到了极点，几乎要哗变了。”而这还是在他们出发之前。这还是在他们出发之前。无论怎样，他们出发了。几个星期后，他们到达了一条叫做
of them? Except for one? He can take one, Brigantine, and then loads of rafts. Why doesn't he wait to fix them? Because it takes ages! And you know, because the people are getting very impatient. And to be honest, I've had to cut out already a lot of feuding. Okay.
马拉尼翁河的河流，这是亚马逊河的主源，它从安第斯山脉发源，一路向东深入丛林，如果他们顺着它漂流，最终会被带向大西洋。是的，他们从西向东，从左到右地前进。真的有一段很长的路要走。那是4000英里。是的，他们根本不打算去大西洋。他们以为自己会进入亚马逊流域，那里会有一个阿兹特克风格的王国，他们可以掠夺那里的黄金，让自己成为那里的主人，然后回到秘鲁说：“太棒了，我们做到了。”所以他们并不是特别担心逆着水流怎么回来。我觉得可以公平地说，他们根本没有把这事想清楚，因为我们很快就会看到，他们中的一些人开始问：“我们要怎么回去？”是的，我想对他们中的一些人来说，这可能一直是一个备选项：他们可能不得不一路向前航行，然后绕过南美洲的最北端返回，我们稍后会重提这个想法。无论如何，过了一会儿，他们发现了第一个印第安村庄。弗雷·西蒙报道说（你知道的），当地人非常令人印象深刻，他们穿着织物的衬衫之类。所以他们（你知道的），这绝对不是一个完全不成熟的文明，
There's been a lot of feuding already. I'm getting a really bad feeling about this. Right. So they all cram into these rafts, but Asua insists on keeping one cabin just for himself and Dona Ines and that does not go down well with the other people on the expedition. As phrase Simon says, the people were in such a state of ill humor that they almost mutinied. And this is before they've left. This is before they've left. Anyway, they set off. After a few weeks, they reach a river called the
但他们没有找到任何黄金。西班牙人变得越来越焦躁不安。不出所料。随着时间的推移，他们深入丛林，有很多私下议论说，苏阿对和多尼娅·伊内斯调情比寻找黄金更感兴趣，根本没有黄金的踪迹，这到底是怎么回事？显然，苏阿发现自己很难在数百名前刑满释放人员中树立权威。这里的控制结构是怎样的？仅仅依靠他的个人魅力吗？是的，他有一系列他雇用的副手，
Maranhon, which is the main source of the Amazon so that runs from the Andes Sort of down and eastwards deep into the jungle so if they follow it they will be swept along ultimately towards The Atlantic yes, they're going from west to east from left to right exactly. I mean it's a heck of a way It's 4,000 miles. Yeah, they're not intending to go to the Atlantic by any means They think they'll go into Amazonia and there'll be a sort of Aztec style kingdom and they can seize its gold, make themselves the masters of it, then go back to Peru and say, brilliant, we've done it. And so they're not particularly worried about how they're going to get back coming up river
他们之间不断地争吵和内讧。我的意思是，这些人——这不是一次军事远征，这些人——他们不是习惯于服从命令的人，这些人习惯于当雇佣兵，他们有点像冒险家。我可不是在乱说话，汤姆，我觉得在这种环境下你会非常不舒服。我一点也不喜欢。不。我会站在一旁直搓手。我的意思是，我和你一起去巡演过，当时只有我们四个人。是的。我简直无法想象你会享受这种氛围，汗水以及不刮胡子（如果这算的话），因为你总是刮得干干净净的。
against the current. They have not thought this through, I think it's fair to say, because we shall see quite quickly they start to some of them say how are we getting back? Yeah I think for some of them it probably is always an option that they may have to continue all the way and then loop around the top of South America and we shall return to this idea. Anyway after a while they find their first native villages. Frey Simmon reports that you know the people were very impressive, they had woven cloth sort of shirts and things. So they had, you know, this is not a totally unsophisticated civilization by any means,
我是。无论如何，他们继续顺流而下。弗雷·西蒙对苏阿的评价是：他太仁慈了，有时他的行为带有软弱的色彩。但随后他做出了那种软弱领导者常做的经典举动，那就是不时地大发雷霆，对人们进行随意的严厉惩罚。所以人们会说：“好吧，你根本不知道他在想什么。他根本不讲原则。”所以他们很不高兴。
but they don't find any gold. And the Spaniards become increasingly restless. Surprise surprise. As the weeks go by and they go deeper and deeper into the jungle, there's a lot of muttering that a sewer is more interested in dallying with Donnie and yes than finding gold there's no hint of gold what's going on clearly a sewer finds it very difficult to impose his authority on all these hundreds of kind of ex cons what is the structure of control does just depend on his charisma or yeah and he has a series of lifts their tenants that he employs who are
他们一度抓到一个印第安女孩，然后问她：“奥雷亚纳多年前顺流而下亚马逊河时遇到的那些人，叫做阿马瓜的那些人，他们在哪里？”她回答说：“我从来没听说过这些人。”他们惊恐地意识到，我们可能距离这些人居住的地方有几百英里远。如果黄金国真的存在，它可能在2000英里之外。因为我想在一个你根本不知道地标在哪里的丛林里，距离直接变成了一个抽象概念。
constantly bickering and feuding among themselves I mean these are people who there's not a military expedition these are not people who are constantly bickering and feuding among themselves. I mean these are people who, it's not a military expedition, these are not people who are used to following orders, these are people who are used to being their mercenaries, they're kind of adventurers. I don't want to speak out of turn Tom, I feel that you would be very uncomfortable in this environment. I wouldn't like it at all. No. I'd stand on the margins wringing my hands. I mean I've been on tour with you when there was just four of us. Yeah. And I just can't see you enjoying this atmosphere, the sweat and the lack of shaving, if nothing else, because you're always a clean shaver man.
而且没有像样的地图。是的。对一切都没有概念，只有那一望无际的绿色、灌木丛中滑动的蛇的声音，以及夜晚尖叫的奇怪猴子——基本上就是这些。他们打着呼噜，完全没错。过了一会儿，他们的船工显然极不称职，导致另一艘双桅轻帆船漏水了，
I am. Anyway, they proceed down the river. Frey Simons says of Usua, he's too merciful and at times his acts savored of weakness. But then he does that classic thing that quite weak leaders do, which is from time to time, he kind of lashes out and inflicts severe punishments on people randomly. And so people say, well, you don't know where you stand with him. You know, he's not consistent. So they're not happy.
他们不得不把船上的所有东西都搬到木筏上。所以德国版的电影与现实几乎没有共同之处，但它确实有一点很符合现实，那就是大量的竹筏戏。这确实很贴近生活，因为他们确实坐在这些木筏上，接着下起了倾盆大雨，然后是雨季。到1560年圣诞节时，正值雨季，雨下个不停，他们没有避雨的地方，全身湿透，食物吃光了，痛苦不堪，而且彻底迷失了方向。正是在这个时候，阿基雷真正登上了故事的舞台。他和他的一个同伙——一个叫萨尔·杜恩多的人——四处闲逛，向其他人低声抱怨。
They capture an Indian girl at one point and they say, these people that Oriana met who are called the Amagwa, you know, all these years ago when he went down the Amazon, where are they? And she says, well, I've never heard of these people. And they realise with a sense of horror, we could be hundreds of miles from where these people live. If El Dorado exists, it could be 2000 miles away. Because I suppose in a jungle where you have no idea what the landmarks are, distance just becomes an abstraction.
首先，阿基雷说，关于黄金国的这套生意显然纯粹是无稽之谈。这就像是一个愚蠢的儿童故事。如果我们真的那么想要黄金，就应该回秘鲁去，在秘鲁大肆掠夺，抢走秘鲁的黄金。其次，他说，苏阿是个糟糕的领袖。他把所有的时间都花在他的情妇多尼娅·伊内斯身上，她基本上才是这次远征真正的女主人。他很自私，——请允许我引用原话——“吝于付出，乐于接受”，我很喜欢这个说法——他要逼着我们在这个丛林里待到满头白灰的老头子，你知道的，如果我们不采取行动，我们就会越陷越深，最终
And no proper map. Yeah. No sense of anything really but just the sort of the green vastness and the sound of the snakes slithering in the undergrowth and strange monkeys screaming in the night you know that's basically what they snoring exactly now after a while this other brigantine their shipwrights are clearly massively incompetent because this other brigantine springs a leak
彻底迷失方向，然后全都死在这里。我觉得他这两点都说得挺有道理的？我的意思是，他没说错。阿基雷在许多方面确实是个疯子，正如我们将会看到的，即使按照《历史的 Rest》的标准，他的行为也恶劣得难以置信；但在这一点上，他其实并没有说错。是的。所以当他四处散播这些言论时，大家就会问：“那谁来当头儿呢？”阿基雷倒也算坦荡，他没有说“我自己来”。他说：“我们当中有一个同行的年轻贵族，名叫堂·费尔南多·德·古斯曼。他的出身和功绩配得上更高的荣誉。”他走向古斯曼，对古斯曼说：“听着，如果我们除掉了苏阿，而你接管了远征队的领导权，腓力二世最初可能会恼火，但当他听到具体情况后，他会认为这是一件好事，并会给予你特殊的奖励。”他这时对堂·费尔南多说：“听着，我们不会杀苏阿，我们只是把他丢在河岸边或者什么地方。”顺便说一句，我的意思是，那实际上就等于杀死他。我想——这不像是他能在丛林里开始新生活。总之，正如你对一个到处自称“堂·费尔南多”的人所能预料的那样，堂·费尔南多是个极度虚荣的人。没错。
and they have to move everything out of there onto these rafts. So the German film version bears very little resemblance to reality, but the one thing it does have is a lot of raft action. And that is true to life because they are on these rafts, starts pouring rain, then the rainy season, by Christmas 1560, it's the rainy season, it's constantly raining, they've got no shelter, they're soaked, they've run out of food, they're really miserable and they are totally and utterly lost. And this is when Aguirre really enters the story. He and one of his mates, who's a man called Sal Duendo, are going round and muttering to the others.
而且他——请允许我引用原话——“被野心的清风吹得膨胀起来，对他们提供的职位表示感谢，并同意了他们所有的计划。”那天晚上空气中弥漫着某种气息，有一个明亮的……阿兰·帕特里奇的儿子叫费尔南多，是的，我觉得这些人非常相似，对吧？所以堂·费尔南多说：“好吧，我加入，开始吧。”就在那时，阿基雷说：“其实有一个小小的改变，说到底我们大概还是会杀了苏阿。”堂·费尔南多对此感到震惊，但他已经陷得太深，自己也牵涉进了这场阴谋中，所以他无法退缩。不过我的意思是，像你刚才说的那样假装心慈手软是很可笑的，因为把他扔在河岸边，意思本来就是死刑。
First of all, Aguirre says, this business about El Dorado is clearly absolute total tosh. Like this is just a stupid children's story. We should go back to Peru and just start rampaging through Peru and steal the gold of Peru if we really want gold that badly. And secondly he says, Asua is a terrible leader. He spends all his time with his mistress, Dona Ines, who's basically the real mistress of the expedition. He is selfish and I quote, an enemy of giving away and a friend to receiving which I quite like as an expression and he is gonna force us to stay in the jungle until we're grey-haired old men and you know if we don't act we're gonna get deeper and deeper and we're gonna be
直接杀了他说不定还更仁慈一点。这也就是我的态度。到这个时候我已经心硬如铁了。你和我在这点上完全不谋而合。所以在1561年的元旦，他们扎营在河边的一个村庄里。苏阿派出了他的一些核心副手去前方侦察，这给他的反对者提供了绝佳的机会。随着夜幕降临，阿基雷的一群手下聚集在苏阿的木屋外面，他们发现苏阿正躺在吊床里和一个
just completely lost and we'll all die. I mean he's got a point with both hasn't he? I mean he's not wrong there. Egiri is a madman in many ways and we shall see he does behave unbelievably badly even by rest his history standards but in this he's not actually wrong. Yeah. So when he goes around saying this people say well who's going to be in charge and Aguirre to his credit he doesn't say myself. He says there's a young nobleman who's traveling with us called Don Fernando de Guzman. His birth and merits are worthy of greater honors and he says to Guzman, he goes to Guzman, he says to him, look if we get rid of Usua and you take over the leadership of the expedition, Philip II may well initially be annoyed but when he hears the circumstances he would consider it a good service and he will specially reward you. And he says to Don Fernando at this point, look we won't kill Usua, we'll just
年轻的随从说话。他对他们说，语气既友好又带着戒备：“各位，你们在这个时候来这里找什么？”我想象现场一定有很多阴恻恻的笑声。他们拔出匕首和刀剑，猛地刺了进去，这就是佩德罗·德·奥苏阿的结局，他死了。然后他们开始大喊——他们喊的内容其实挺有意思的——他们高喊：“自由！自由！国王万岁！暴君已死！”所以在这个时候，他们试图把这包装成是对腓力二世效忠的行为。他们换掉了一个糟糕的领袖，国王一定会非常高兴。暴君死。
leave him by the side of the bank or something. I mean, by the way, I mean, that would be effectively to kill him. I imagine I mean, it's not like he's going to make a new life for himself in the jungle. Anyway, Don Fernando, as I think is you can expect with the man who goes around calling himself Don Fernando, he's a very vain man. Right. And he is and I quote, swelled up by the wind of ambition he gave thanks for what they offered him and assented to all their projects there was something in the air that night there was a bright Alan Partridge's son is
完全正确。营地里一片混乱，因为人们能听到喊叫声和尖叫声。他们又屠杀了苏阿的另一位副手，一个穿着棉质盔甲、名叫巴尔加斯的男人。所以这是德国电影搞错的一个地方。在德国电影里，他们都穿着巨大的金属盔甲，但实际上他们穿的是阿兹特克或印加风格的、填充了棉花的绗缝盔甲。不过金属盔甲看起来确实更有汗流浃背的效果。我的意思是，这对视觉效果很好。而在电影里穿着一件棉被看起来太荒谬了。一点威慑力都没有。不，不，不。然后当然，带着惊人的可预测性，他们立刻冲进了酒窖。他们把这些
called Fernando yeah I imagine these people as being very similar right so don't for now it says right I'm in okay let's get this plot started and at that point a gear a says yeah there's one slight change actually we probably will kill us you after all. And Don Fernando is shocked by this, but he's in too deep, he's implicated in the plot, so he can't back out. But I mean, it's ridiculous to be squeamish as you said, because to just dump him on the side of the river, I mean, is a death sentence anyway.
酒喝得精光，烂醉如泥。他们把苏阿的其他同伙抓起来，把他们也杀了。他们没有杀多尼娅·伊内斯。我正要问她呢。她的命运如何？所以她只是呆在自己的木屋里。此时没有提到她，我们知道后来有提到她，所以她大概正在自己的小屋里瑟瑟发抖、万分焦虑。我的意思是，这些人看起来可不像是那种对刚刚杀害的人的情妇保持百分之百骑士风度的人。我不得不告诉听众们，如果你们已经对她这个角色产生了深厚的感情，那下半部分听起来可就极具挑战了。于是他们第二天顶着巨大的宿醉集合起来，由堂·费尔南多担任新领袖，他说：“我决定我们继续寻找黄金国，因为当我们找到所有的黄金时，国王会原谅这些谋杀，
Probably more merciful to kill him. That would be my attitude. I would have hardened up by this point. You and I are completely on the same page on this. So on New Year's Day 1561, they're camped in this village by the side of the river. Asua has sent some of his key lieutenants to scout ahead, and that gives his opponents the perfect opportunity. And as darkness falls, a group of Aguirre's men gather outside Asua's hut, and they find him lying in his hammock talking to a
并会给予我们丰厚的奖励。所以我们应该起草一份文件来解释……”西班牙人太死板了，不是吗？他们在征服墨西哥时一直这么干。还记得我们做那个系列的时候吗？他们总是起草公告，向那些根本听不懂的人宣读法律文件之类。所以我有一个问题：这是一次极其危险的远征，每个人都知道这里有疾病、野生动物、带着吹箭的人以及各种乱七八糟的东西，他们为什么还要承认谋杀了这个家伙？他们为什么不随便编个借口，说他死于某种疾病之类呢？我的意思是，这看起来有点奇怪。
pageboy. And he says to them, sort of in a friendly but suspicious way, Caballeros, what seek ye here at this hour? And they kind of, I imagine there's a lot of cackling. They draw their knives and swords, plunge them in and that is the end of Pedro de Osirio, he is dead. And then they start shouting, it's interesting what they shout actually, they start, Liberty, Liberty, long live the king, the tyrant is dead. So at this point they're trying to dress it up as an act of loyalty to Philip II. They've had a bad leader, they've got rid and the king will be very happy. Six semper tyrannus.
他们有那么多人呢，别忘了他们有400人。我猜他们觉得消息总会走漏的。也是。是的，我猜是的。而且因为其中一些人并没有参与这个阴谋，可能对此有点不满。所以他们觉得最好还是有个借口。于是他们起草了这份讲究法律形式的文件。
Exactly. The camp is in total uproar because people can hear the shouting and screaming. They butcher another of Ursua's lieutenants who's a man called Vargas who's come out in his cotton armour. So this is one thing the German film gets wrong. They're all wearing enormous metal armour in the German film but in reality they'd have worn sort of Aztec or Inca style cotton padded quilted armour. But the metal makes them look sweatier. I mean it's a good for the visuals. And wearing a quilt in a film just looks ridiculous. It's not intimidating. No no no. So then of course, with staggering predictability, they immediately break into the wine stores. They all drink this
确实。营地里一片混乱，因为人们能听到喊叫声和尖叫声。他们又杀害了乌苏阿的另一位副官，一个名叫巴尔加斯的男人，他穿着棉质盔甲出来。所以这是德国电影搞错的一点。德国电影里他们都穿着巨大的金属盔甲，但实际上他们穿的是阿兹卡或印加风格的棉质绗缝盔甲。不过金属让他们看起来流汗更多。我的意思是这对视觉效果很好。在电影里穿被子看起来太荒谬了。一点也不吓人。不不不。所以接下来，不出意料地，他们立刻闯入酒窖。他们把这些
wine get absolutely wasted. They round up us you as other mates, they kill them as well. They don't kill Donya Ines. I was going to ask about her. What's her fate? So she's just hanging around in her own heart. She's not mentioned at this point, we know she's mentioned later on so she's just presumably quaking in her heart very anxious. I mean these don't seem the kind of guys who would necessarily be 100% chivalrous towards the mistress of someone they've just killed. I have to tell the listeners if they've already formed a great attachment to her as a character the second half will make will make challenging listening. So they then assemble the next day with massive hangovers and Don Fernando is the new leader and he says, I've decided we'll continue the search for El Dorado because when we find all this gold, the king will forgive the murders and
酒喝得酩酊大醉。他们把你的其他同伙抓起来，把他们也杀了。他们没有杀多尼亚·伊内斯。我正想问她呢。她的命运如何？所以她就呆在自己的帐篷里。此时没有提到她，我们知道后来提到了她，所以她大概在帐篷里瑟瑟发抖，非常焦虑。我的意思是，这些人看起来不像是会对他们刚杀的人的情妇百分之百有骑士风度的人。我得告诉听众们，如果他们已经对她这个角色产生了深厚的感情，那么下半部分听起来会很有挑战性。于是他们在第二天顶着巨大的宿醉集合了，唐·费尔南多成为了新首领，他说，我决定我们将继续寻找黄金国，因为当我们找到所有这些黄金时，国王会原谅谋杀，并且
he will give us handsome rewards. So we should draw up a document explaining the Spanish are so legalistic, aren't they? They did this all the time in the conquest of Mexico. Do you remember when we did that serious They're always drawing up requirements and reading out legal documents to people who don't understand them and things So I've got a question which is this is a highly dangerous expedition Everyone knows that this disease and wild animals and people with blowpipes and all that kind of stuff Why would they ever confess to having murdered this guy? Why don't they just say, oh, he died of some disease or something? I mean, it just seems a bit odd.
他会给我们丰厚的奖励。所以我们应该起草一份文件——西班牙人真是太重法理了，不是吗？他们在征服墨西哥时一直这么做。还记得我们做那个系列的时候吗？他们总是起草要求，并向听不懂的人宣读法律文件之类的内容。所以我有这样一个问题：这是一次极其危险的远征。每个人都知道这里有疾病、野生动物、带着吹箭的人以及诸如此类的事情。为什么他们要承认谋杀这家伙？他们为什么不说，哦，他死于某种疾病之类的话？我的意思是，这看起来有点奇怪。
There's a lot of them that remember they were troubled with 400 people. I suppose they think the news will come out. I suppose. Yes, I suppose. And because some of the people there were not party to the plot and perhaps a little bit displeased about it. So they think it's better to have an excuse. So they drew up this legalistic document.
有很多人记得他们有400人。我想他们认为消息会传出去。我想是的。是的，我想是的。而且因为那里的一些人没有参与阴谋，可能对此感到有点不满。所以他们认为有个借口会更好。于是他们起草了这份讲究法理的文件。
Don Fernando signs first and then Aguirre steps up and he signs his name as follows. He writes Lope de Aguirre the traitor. Wow. And there's great gasps and shock and Aguirre laughs. And how does he laugh Dominic? I imagine a demonic laugh at this point. So I'll do a variety of laughs later on. There'll be a lot of opportunities, put it that way. That was terrifying. He says, you have killed the King's governor, one who represented his royal person, clothed with royal powers. We have all been traitors. We have all been a party to this mutiny. I mean, again, he's not wrong, is he?
费 Fernando 先签了字，接着阿吉雷走上前，签下了这样的名字。他写下“叛国者洛佩·德·阿吉雷”。哇。现场一片倒吸凉气和震惊，阿吉雷却笑了。他是怎么笑的，多米尼克？我脑补了一个恶魔般的笑声。那我等会儿会模仿各种各样的笑声。会有很多机会的，这么说吧。这太可怕了。他说，你杀死了国王的总督，一个代表国王本人、身披王权的人。我们全都是叛国者。我们全都参与了这场哗变。我的意思是，话说回来，他说得没错，不是吗？
No. See, again, there is an alternative explanation which is the only sane person in a world of fools. I mean there is a kind of Shakespearean quality to this where it's the villain who speaks the truth like kind of Richard the third or Iago or whoever. Yeah well because of what he says next he then says to the assemble company this business about El Dorado is demented even if we found it, there is no way Philip II would allow us to keep it. He would send in viceroy's and governors and bureaucrats. It's madness to be wasting our time on this. We should go back to Peru. There's a load of treasure there. Let's kill everybody in Peru and take the treasure. That's just a much more sensible way of proceeding. There's a huge argument. The council breaks up and
没有。你看，这里还有另一种解释，那就是他是愚者世界里唯一清醒的人。这种感觉有点像莎士比亚式的戏剧，反派却说出了真相，比如理查三世、伊阿古或诸如此类的人物。对，因为他接下来所说的话，他接着对聚集的人群说，关于黄金国的这套把戏纯属疯话，就算我们找到了，腓力二世也绝不可能让我们占有它。他会派总督、地方长官和官僚来。把时间浪费在这上面简直是疯了。我们应该回秘鲁去。那儿有数不尽的宝藏。咱们把秘鲁所有人都杀光，然后把宝藏抢走。这才是合理得多的行事方式。于是爆发了一场激烈的争论。委员会不欢而散，
this issue is unresolved. So they set off downstream again, deeper and deeper into the Amazon. Now, by this point, Aguirre has clearly realized what perhaps some of the others have not yet woken up to. There is no way actually that they're going to be able to get back upstream. Because by now the current is getting stronger and stronger. It's really strong. You know, the Amazon, these are big rivers. There is no way with these terrible rafts that they're going to be able to go
这个问题悬而未决。于是他们再次顺流而下，深入亚马逊腹地。到了这个时候，阿吉雷显然已经意识到了一些其他人可能还没察觉到的事情。他们实际上根本不可能再逆流而上了。因为此时水流越来越急。水势非常猛。你知道的，亚马逊河，这些都是大江大河。就凭他们这些破木筏，根本不可能
back the other way. You know, the more I hear about him, the more you like him, the more I like him and the more I think I would have rallied behind him. Well, we'll see if you could maintain that position in the second half. I'm aware that it doesn't end well. So they now discover they've got massive holes in their rafts. They have to stop by the side of the river and build new ships. That takes them three months. I mean day after day, hammering and stuff, you know, cutting down trees to make nails and planks and things. They've got no food, they're living off wild fruit and I have to say their own horses because they had horses on these rafts so they're now eating them and Aguirre actually is quite pleased about this because he thinks if we eat all our
原路返回。你知道的，听到的关于他的事越多，你就越喜欢他，我也越喜欢他，我就越觉得当时应该紧跟在他身后。好吧，我们拭目以待你在下半场还能不能保持这个立场。我知道这结局并不美好。现在他们发现自己的木筏上到处都是大洞。他们不得不停在河岸边建造新船。这花了他们三个月的时间。我是说日复一日地敲敲打打，你知道的，砍树来做钉子、木板之类的东西。他们没有食物，靠野果维生，我还得说，还有他们自己的马，因为他们的木筏上带了马，所以现在他们在吃马肉，而阿吉雷其实对此挺高兴的，因为他觉得如果我们把所有的
animals there's no way we can sort of settle down or be tempted to capture towns and you know all this stuff we'll just have to keep going all the way to the Atlantic and get out of here which is basically what I want to do and I think it's about this point that the mood really really starts to darken what do you mean starts to darken yeah Yeah, because that was all prellies. That was all quite jolly. Because previously when they'd got on reasonably well with the native population, they had done a bit of trading. Of course, there'd been a bit of violence, but nothing completely off the scale. Now there's a lot of fighting and basically the word spreads the Spaniards are bad guys.
牲口都吃光了，我们就绝对没办法安顿下来，也不会经受不住诱惑去占领城镇，你知道的诸如此类，我们就只能一路走到大西洋，然后离开这里，这基本上就是我想做的事。我觉得大概就是在这一刻，气氛真的开始变得阴暗起来。你说的变得阴暗是什么意思？对，因为之前那些都只是前奏。之前那些都挺欢乐的。因为之前他们和当地土著相处得还算融洽，还做了一点贸易。当然，也有过一点暴力冲突，但没到完全失控的地步。现在战斗变多了，基本上消息传开了，西班牙人都是坏蛋。
And whenever they go out to look for food food they're often ambushed by Indians. There's also a huge row, one of endless huge rows inside the camp. Some of Don Fernando's friends say, look you actually need to get rid of Aguirre, but he doesn't have the guts. He demotes him as second in command and the problem is Aguirre, as we've established, is a very vengeful man. So Aguirre just notes this slight, he hides his fury and resentment, but he's determined one day that he will get his revenge. So we come to March 1561. Don Fernando and Aguirre call
而且每当他们出去找食物时，经常会遭到印第安人的伏击。营地内部也爆发了激烈的争吵，这是无数次激烈争吵中的一次。费 Fernando 的一些朋友说，听着，你真的得除掉阿吉雷，但他没有这个胆量。他把阿吉雷降职为副指挥官，问题是阿吉雷正如我们所知，是个非常记仇的人。所以阿吉雷只是记下了这个羞辱，他隐藏了自己的愤怒和怨恨，但决心总有一天要报仇雪恨。时间来到了1561年3月。费 Fernando 和阿吉雷召集了
another meeting. You can sense that the mood is getting very paranoid. They begin by demanding that every man pledge his loyalty to Don Fernando by God and the Virgin and then Aguirre addresses the men and he says Look, we've been talking the plan has changed. We are gonna forget about El Dorado now We are going to seize the wealth of Peru and we will crown Don Fernando Guzman Our general by the grace of God Lord and Prince of Peru the main and Chile to whom by right these kingdoms belong." Wow, there's a twist. He says, we for swear our allegiance to the King of Spain and Aguirre makes this huge pronouncement. He says, from this day forward I pledge myself to my Prince, King and natural Lord Don Fernando and I swear and promise to be his faithful vassal and to die in his defense. So that's a death sentence, isn't it? And then he turns to Fernando, he bows and in front of everybody, he kisses his hand
另一次会议。你能感觉到气氛变得非常疑神疑鬼。他们首先要求每个人向费 Fernando 宣誓效忠，向上帝和圣母发誓，然后阿吉雷向众人发表讲话，他说，听着，我们已经商量过了，计划有变。我们现在要把黄金国的事忘掉。我们要夺取秘鲁的财富，我们要加冕费尔南多·古斯曼为我们的总司令，奉天承人、秘鲁及智利的主权与亲王，这些王国理应归他所有。”哇，这真是个大反转。他说，我们宣布解除对西班牙国王的效忠，阿吉雷发表了这番重大的声明。他说，从今天起，我誓死效忠我的亲王、国王和自然领主费 Fernando，我发誓并承诺做他忠实的臣民，为捍卫他而死。这简直是一份死刑判决书，对吧？然后他转向费 Fernando，鞠躬并在众人面前吻了他的手，
as the new Prince of Peru. And Tom, I hate to tell you, but with that traitor's kiss, the real nightmare begins. Brilliant Dominic. Okay, so it's been an absolute pleasure jaunt up until now, but in the second half we will find out how, as Dominic just said, the nightmare begins. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History. We are with Aguirre, the Wrath of God, the Traitor, El Loco, the Madman, the Epithets are piling up and Dominic, none of them are good and none of them looking good for Don Fernando
承认他为秘鲁的新亲王。汤姆，我很遗憾地告诉你，随着那个叛徒之吻，真正的噩梦开始了。太精彩了，多米尼克。好吧，到现在为止这还是一次绝对愉快的郊游，但在下半场我们将发现，正如多米尼克刚刚所说，噩梦是如何开始的。你好，欢迎回到“历史的其余部分”。我们正和被称为上帝之怒、叛国者、疯子埃尔·洛科的阿吉雷在一起，各种外号层出不穷，多米尼克，没有一个好听的，对费 Fernando 来说也全无好兆头。
Who is in nominal charge has just been proclaimed by gear a basically Lord of the whole of South America So he must be feeling pretty pleased, but I'm guessing Don't know just something telling me he's not gonna be around for long. Guess what the clock is ticking for Don Fernando So he's the Prince of Peru, but they're lost in the middle of the jungle. So it's fair to say his title is purely nominal at this point. And Aguirre says, look, this is how we're going to get out.
名义上的负责人刚刚被吉尔宣称为基本上整个南美洲的领主，所以他现在一定自我感觉相当良好，但我猜——不知道，总有什么东西告诉我他不会活太久了。你猜怎么着，费 Fernando 的倒计时已经开始啦。所以他是秘鲁亲王，但他们迷失在丛林中央。所以可以说，此时他的头衔纯粹是个名义。阿吉雷说，看，这就是我们脱困的方法。
I've got my plan. We'll finish building these brigantines, these ships. When they're ready, we will sail all the way down the Amazon, another 2000 miles or whatever to the Atlantic, dead easy. Then we will head to an island called Margarita, which is off the coast of Venezuela. There there's a Spanish base. We will take that base. We'll get supplies. We'll recruit people there. Then he says, we'll sail up to Panama. We'll seize the capital. We'll kill all the royal officials.
我已经有计划了。我们造完这些双桅帆船，也就是这些船。它们准备好后，我们将顺着亚马逊河一直向下航行，再走2000英里左右到达大西洋，这轻而易举。然后我们前往一个叫做玛格丽塔的岛屿，它在委内瑞拉海岸附近。那里有一个西班牙基地。我们将夺取那个基地。我们将获得补给。我们将在那里招募人手。接着他说，我们将航行到巴拿马。我们将占领首都。我们将杀死所有皇室官员。
We'll take control of the Spanish fleet based in Panama. We will rally the colonists of Central America and we will cross the isthmus of Panama and launch a seaborne invasion of Peru and seize the gold of Peru now if you were standing in the middle of the jungle Soaked with rain you've only eaten Kind of over ripe fruit for the past month and a horse and Dominic. I'm imagining a lot of leeches Yeah loads of leeches And Dominic, I'm imagining a lot of leeches. Yeah, loads of leeches. When someone outlined this plan to you, which involves a lot of travel, a lot of capturing of implausible captures in your fleets,
我们将控制驻扎在巴拿马的西班牙舰队。我们将集结中美洲的殖民者，横跨巴拿马地峡，对秘鲁发动海上入侵，夺取秘鲁的黄金。现在，如果你站在丛林中央，被雨水淋透，过去一个月里只吃了点过熟的水果和一匹马，而且多米尼克，我想象有很多水蛭。是的，到处都是水蛭。而且多米尼克，我想象有很多水蛭。是的，到处都是水蛭。当有人向你勾勒出这个计划时，它涉及大量的旅行，在你的舰队中进行大量不可思议的占领，
crossing of isthmuses and multiple South American countries, you might say, I find this implausible. You might equally say, well, what's the alternative? Yeah, well, that's what they say. They say, fine, let's give it a go. Why not? What's the worst that could happen? I think it's fair to say they haven't really thought that through because the worst that can happen is probably a lot worse than they're imagining.
横跨地峡以及多个南美国家，你可能会说，我觉得这太不可思议了。你同样可能会说，好吧，那还有什么别的选择呢？对，没错，他们就是这么说的。他们说，好吧，那就试试看呗。为什么不呢？最坏能发生什么？我觉得公平地说，他们根本没有深思熟虑，因为可能发生的最坏情况大概比他们想象的要糟糕得多。
Well, I'm not sure about that, actually. I mean, being proactive is better than just sitting there and being eaten by leeches and dying in the middle of nowhere. That's true. At least to try. And as we'll see, maybe they had a few laughs along the way. So they set off, they go into the river network again of Amazonia, eventually they built the ships.
嗯，其实我不太确定。我的意思是，积极主动总比坐在那里被水蛭吃掉、死在荒郊野岭要强。这倒也是。至少去尝试过了。正如我们所看到的，也许他们一路上还挺开心的。于是他们出发了，再次进入亚马逊的河流网络，最终他们建成了船只。
We're in April 1561. This is the point at which Robert Silverberg says in his book, in all the records of South American conquest, Aguirre stands out as the only man who ever went to great lengths to avoid finding El Dorado. Because whenever they see an interesting looking tributary, he says, don't even look at it, keep going, he's got his plan, he doesn't want anything to interfere with it. Again he's right! Of course he is, they don't want to get lost in this maze of rivers. It's a terrible sort of labyrinth, a sort of riverine labyrinth, they're eating fish, they are living off turtles and
时间来到了1561年4月。这就是罗伯特·西尔维伯格在他的书中指出的一点：在南美征服的所有记录中，阿吉雷是唯一一个竭尽全力避免找到黄金国的人。因为每当他们看到一条看起来有趣的支流时，他就说，看都别看，继续走，他有自己的计划，他不想让任何事情干扰到它。他又做对了！当然了，他们可不想在这个河流迷宫里迷路。这是一种可怕的迷宫，一种河流迷宫，他们吃鱼，靠海龟和
manatees. That's terrible, manatees are endangered. Perhaps this is why. El Loco. They're all incredibly emaciated, They're all going a bit mad. After a few weeks, Don Fernando, who's still hanging around, some of his friends say to him, this is mad. I mean, the El Dorado thing was pretty mad. But this idea about looping around and conquering Peru is absolutely bonkers. It's never going to work. Let's get rid of Aguirre. But they delay too long. They talk about about it but they don't do it they have a sort of complicated plan they're going to invite him aboard a ship and stab him and all this
海牛维生。这太糟糕了，海牛是濒危动物。也许这就是原因所在。疯子。他们都骨瘦如柴，一个个都有点发疯了。几个星期后，依然赖着不走的费 Fernando，他的一些朋友对他说，这太疯狂了。我是说，黄金国那事已经够疯狂的了。但这个绕道去征服秘鲁的想法简直荒谬透顶。这根本行不通。咱们把阿吉雷除掉吧。但他们犹豫了太久。他们商量来商量去却没有动手，他们有个复杂的计划，打算邀请他上船然后把他捅死之类的，
and in the meantime word leaks out and so Aguirre finds out about it and he decides he will strike first so the first person that he gets rid of is his friend Señor Sal Duendo who had been his ally earlier on he's started sleeping with Dona Ines and Aguirre finds that disgraceful. And he denounces his former friend as a traitor. He sends his men to overpower him and to butcher him with knives, which they do. He says, actually Dona Ines is a massive drain on this expedition and a distraction. She's got to go. And he sends two of his henchmen, who are called Carion and Yomoso. Yomoso will be reappearing in this story in a colourful manner. These two guys
与此同时消息走漏了，于是阿吉雷发现了这件事，他决定先下手为强。所以他除掉的第一个人是他的朋友萨尔·杜恩多先生，此人早期曾是他的盟友，但他开始和多娜·伊内斯睡觉，阿吉雷觉得这有辱斯文。他谴责他曾经的朋友是个叛徒。他派手下制服了他，并用刀将他残忍杀害，他们也确实这么做了。他说，其实多娜·伊内斯是这次远征的一个巨大累赘和分心因素。她必须得死。他派了他的两个心腹去，一个叫卡里翁，另一个叫约莫索。约莫索接下来会以一种很戏剧化的方式在这故事里再次登场。这两个家伙
turn up with daggers to kill Dona Ines and the various chroniclers and eyewitness accounts really go to town on this. They're said to have stabbed her so ferociously that she drowned in her own blood. One account says they took an unnatural delight in mangling what had once been so beautiful. Another, even the most hardened men in the camp at the sight of the mangled, that word again, the mangled victim, were broken hearted, for this was the cruelest act that had ever been perpetrated. But Aguirre, he doesn't mind. His thinks it's great.
带着匕首出现，准备杀死多娜·伊内斯，各种编年史和目击者的记述对这一幕大加渲染。据说他们捅得极为凶狠，以至于她溺死在自己的血泊中。有一份记载说，他们从虐杀曾经如此美丽的人身上获得了变态的快感。另一份则说，营地里最铁石心肠的人看到那被虐杀——又是这个词——被虐杀的受害者时，也无不心碎，因为这是有史以来最残酷的行径。但阿吉雷并不介意。他觉得这太棒了。
I mean, it's what he wanted. It's what he ordered. So that's not true, because he's clearly the most hardened man in the camp and he doesn't care. Yeah, that's true. Actually, you're quite right. And you've pointed out a terrible discrepancy in the sources. I have. Oh, Tom, this is the kind of forensic detail that marks us out as a great history podcast. So Don Fernando has been sort of watching all this impotently and is horrified. But as our sources say, he now has just become a quivering
我的意思是，这就是他想要的。这就是他下令做的。所以这不是真的，因为他显然是营地里最铁石心肠的人，而且他根本不在乎。是的，这倒也是。其实，你说得完全对。而且你指出了资料中一个可怕的出入。我确实指出来了。哦，汤姆，这就是那种能让我们成为一档伟大历史播客的细节考究。所以费 Fernando 一直在无能为力地看着这一切，感到惊恐万分。但正如我们的资料所说，他现在已经变成了一个战战兢兢的
jelly of a man. He became fearful and changed in appearance, but he didn't protect his person with more care, nor take Aguirre's life, nor seek to rally more friends, for he had become so timid and listless that for care of his own life he took but little note. It seemed that he carried death in his eyes. So the end comes for him a few days later. they're camped on an island in the middle of the river. Aguirre's men burst into his hut, they kill his chaplain first, stabbed him so ferociously that the sword pinned him to the mattress. Then they go by Don Fernando's kind of hammock and he wakes, and Aguirre said to him very gently, don't be alarmed, your excellency.
软体动物般的男人。他变得胆小怕事，外貌也变了，但他却没有更小心地保护自己，也没有取走阿吉雷的性命，更没有去争取更多朋友，因为他变得如此胆怯和冷漠，以至于对自己的生命也鲜少关注。似乎死亡已经写在他的眼底。于是几天后，他的末日终于来临了。他们扎营在河中央的一座岛上。阿吉雷的手下冲进他的小屋，先杀死了他的牧师，那一剑刺得如此凶狠，竟然把牧师钉在了床垫上。然后他们走到费 Fernando 的吊床旁，他醒了过来，据说阿吉雷非常温和地对他说，别惊慌，阁下。
And then they killed all Don Fernando's friends while he was just sort of lying there in his hammock looking mournful. And then they shot Don Fernando with their arquebuses and hacked him to pieces with their swords and threw him in the river. So that's the end of him. So he never becomes King of Peru. He never became King of Peru at all. He just floated down the Amazon in bits. It's a warning never to have dreams above your station.
然后他们杀死了费 Fernando 的所有朋友，而他当时就躺在吊床上一脸哀戚地看着。接着他们用火绳枪射击费 Fernando，用剑把他砍成碎块，然后扔进了河里。他的死期就此到来。所以他从来没有成为秘鲁国王。他根本就没当过秘鲁国王。他只是变成了碎块顺着亚马逊河漂走了。这真是一个警告：永远不要有超出自己身份的非分之想。
That's what it is. That's exactly what it is. You should always be kept in check. Accept your lot, don't aim high, don't follow your dream. So the next morning everybody wakes up and Aguirre addresses the whole camp and he says look I did this for the safety of the army because if Don Fernando had been allowed to live we'd all have perished. He says please everybody he says please consider me from now onwards your friend and companion. You will not be disappointed for you can scarcely conceive how much I desire to administer to your pleasure and contentment.
事情就是这样。完全就是这样。你永远都得安分守己。接受你的命运，别志存高远，别追逐你的梦想。于是第二天早上每个人醒来后，阿吉雷向整个营地发表讲话，他说，听着，我这么做是为了军队的安全，因为如果让费 Fernando 活着，我们全都得完蛋。他说，请大家，他说，从今以后请把我当作你们的朋友和同伴。你们不会失望的，因为你们简直无法想象我是多么渴望满足你们的快乐和惬意。
And he says to maximise everybody's pleasure and contentment a few quick ground rules from now on all private conversations are outlawed and you can no longer go around in groups to stop conspiracy. To stop conspiracies, we can have no more of this plotting. I mean that's rich given from the chief plotter but he says look there's been far too much plotting and he also appoints a kind of praetorian guard for himself of Basques with arquebuses. So actually behind that I think there may be a sort of serious point which is that there are clearly internal feuds and rivalries. Aguirre is a Basque himself and it may well be that it's very hard for us to detect. There is perhaps an issue here between Castilians and Basques or something like that.
为了最大程度地让每个人感到快乐和惬意，他宣布了从今以后的一些简短基本规则：所有私人谈话一律取缔，你们不能再成群结队地行动，以防范阴谋。为了制止阴谋，我们绝不能再有这种勾结了。这话由这个头号阴谋家说出来可真够讽刺的，但他说，看，之前的阴谋实在太多了。他还为自己任命了一支由手持火绳枪的巴斯克人组成的近卫军。所以实际上，在那背后的表象下，我认为可能有一个比较严肃的点，那就是内部显然存在着地盘之争和敌对情绪。阿吉雷本人就是巴斯克人，这很可能说明——虽然我们很难察觉——卡斯蒂利亚人和巴斯克人之间可能存在着某种矛盾，诸如此类。
And the sources, are they Castilian or Basque? They are Castilian by and large and as we will see the sources, I do believe that a lot of this happened, that a lot of what is being reported is true but I think the spin they are putting on this is very particular as we shall see because these are eyewitnesses who have been part of a rebellion against the King of Spain and want to excuse themselves by explaining how they were being misled by a madman So it may be that Aguirre isn't less mad. Less mad. I mean more like Unai Emery, the Basque manager of Aston Villa. Right, not a madman. Not a madman at all. A very good manager. But you would follow him into the jungle Tom, would you not? I
那么这些历史记载，它们是卡斯蒂利亚人的视角还是巴斯克人的视角？大体上是卡斯蒂利亚人的视角。正如我们将会看到的，虽然我相信很多事情确实发生了，很多报道的事情都是真实的，但我认为他们所加的润色是非常有针对性的，正如我们将要看到的，因为这些目击者曾参与反对西班牙国王的叛乱，他们想通过解释自己是被一个疯子误导来为自己开脱。所以也许阿吉雷并没有那么疯。没那么疯。我的意思是，更像是乌奈·埃梅里，阿斯顿维拉的那位巴斯克主帅。对，不是个疯子。一点也不疯。是个非常优秀的主帅。但你会跟着他进丛林吗，汤姆，你会吗？我
absolutely would. I'd do whatever he said. But I mean if it all went wrong. Would you then smear him as a loco? You claim that he had a limp and stuff? I'd like to think I'd stay loyal. Right, well some of Aguirre's people did stay loyal right to the end. That would be me. I mean if he was like Unai Emery, I mean not if he was like Klaus Kinski. Yes. Just putting that on the record. Fine. Yeah, you wouldn't follow a German is what you're saying. I wouldn't follow a very sweaty guy with bulgy eyeballs who's wearing too much armour, but I would follow a twinkle-eyed
绝对会。他叫我做什么我都听。但如果事情搞砸了呢？你难道不会抹黑他是个疯子（El Loco）吗？说他走路一瘸一拐什么的？我希望自己能保持忠诚。好吧，阿吉雷手下确实有些人至死都保持忠诚。那就会是我。我的意思是，如果他像乌奈·埃梅里——我是说，如果他不像克劳斯·金斯基的话。是的。把这话记到记录里。好吧。对，你是说你不会跟着一个德国人。我不会跟着一个满身大汗、眼球暴突、穿着太多盔甲的家伙，但我会跟着一个眼神狡黠、
charismatic leader of men in a tracksuit or actually Emery's very kind of dapper yeah he's never wears a tracksuit no he doesn't very kind of dapper coat and scarf. Do you know what he is? He's courtly. Yeah he is. A word one would often use of a Spaniard. Yeah courtly is absolutely the word you're right he actually has kind of quite a 16th century face I think like a kind of Cavalier in a an El Greco painting right they're now in I guess where are they they are in northern Brazil they've got completely lost do we know how far they've got to get to the Atlantic now they're well over halfway they are now probably go round about a river called the Rio Negro
风度翩翩、穿着运动服——或者其实埃梅里非常文雅，对，他从来不穿运动服，不，他从不，他总是穿着挺拔的大衣和围巾。你知道他是什么样的人吗？他很有绅士风度。对，他是。人们常常用来形容西班牙人的一个词。对，绅士风度绝对是这个词，你没说错。他其实长着一张很有16世纪面孔的人，我想，就像埃尔·格雷科画作里的那种骑士。对，他们现在在——我猜他们在哪里？他们现在在巴西北部，完全迷路了。我们知道他们距离大西洋还有多远吗？他们已经过了大半程，现在大概正绕着一条叫内格罗河的河流前进，
so they're heading across the border into what is now Venezuela and just to ask no one has ever done this before? No, they have no idea where they are. Now actually at one point they see campfires, they see lights burning on the horizon and they have a few guides left, a few native guides. Some of the guides say, God, this could be it. This could be the land of the Amagua, these people who are very rich. And Aguirre is furious at this.
所以他们正跨越边境进入现在的委内瑞拉。顺便问一句，以前从来没有人这样做过吗？没有，他们根本不知道自己在哪。现在，事实上，有那么一刻他们看到了营火，看到地平线上有灯光在燃烧，他们还剩几个向导，几个当地向导。其中一些向导说，天哪，这可能就是了。这可能就是阿玛瓜人的土地，这些人非常富有。而阿吉雷对此大发雷霆。
He says on pain of death, nobody is to look at this town or talk about it or mention the Amagwa again, because he's really wedded to this plan of sailing around the top of South America and then crossing the Isthmus of Panama and then seizing the gold of Peru. He's right. Well, he's also at this point, very, very paranoid. So Fray Simon says, so many were the fears that disturbed the wicked conscience of Aguirre, that although
他下令以死相威胁，任何人都不准看这座城镇，不准谈论它，也不准再提起阿玛瓜人，因为他真的铁了心要执行这个计划：绕过南美洲最北端，然后横跨巴拿马地峡，接着夺取秘鲁的黄金。他做得很对。嗯，此时此刻他也变得非常非常疑神疑鬼。所以弗雷·西蒙说，种种恐惧扰乱了阿吉雷那邪恶的良心，以至于尽管
he'd killed those whom he feared, he never felt secure from the survivors. And I think that's definitely true. At this point, he really starts getting into his garroting. So there hasn't been a lot of garroting so far, but now, I mean, I can't stop the narrative every five minutes for all the garroting. Just assume that it's constant. I mean I can't stop the narrative every five minutes for all the grotting just assume that it's constant I mean it's a more merciful way to go than stabbing someone to death so perhaps he's coming around to him well this I think you would disagree with Tom because I think there's a hint of a kind of satanic nihilism I love it a satanic nihilist so phrase Simon says that Aguirre at this point banned his men from praying and he said throw away your rosaryary beads, you don't need them. He said, if you're worried about your souls,
他杀死了那些让他感到恐惧的人，但他对幸存者从来没有感到过安全。我想这绝对是真的。就在这时，他真正开始迷恋上绞杀刑了。所以到目前为止还没有太多的绞杀，但现在，我是说，我不能每隔五分钟就为了所有的绞刑而打断叙事。大家就默认这种事一直在发生吧。我是说，我不能每隔五分钟就为了所有的绞刑而打断叙事，就默认它是源源不断的吧。绞刑比把人捅死要仁慈一点，所以也许他在这方面有所转变……好吧，我想你不会同意这一点，汤姆，因为我觉得这其中隐约透出一种撒旦式的虚无主义。我太喜欢了，一个撒旦式的虚无主义者！所以弗雷·西蒙说，阿吉雷此时禁止他的手下祈祷，他说，扔掉你们的玫瑰经念珠吧，你们不需要它们。他说，如果你们担心自己的灵魂，
you should play dice with the devil. It's a good phrase. And then he says, he's very Friedrich Nietzsche actually. He said, he told his men that God had heaven for those who chose to serve him, but that the earth was for the strongest. He knew for certain there was no salvation and that being in life was to be in hell and that he would commit every species of wickedness and cruelty so that his name might ring throughout the earth and even to the ninth heaven he's like the judge in blood Meridian yeah blood Meridian or the Marquis de Sade or something there's a a kind of ideological sadism to him, I think, of this, but if this is to be believed. They now enter the Orinoco River and the river
你们应该去和魔鬼掷骰子。这话说得真好。然后他说，他其实非常有弗里德里希·尼采的风范。他对手下说，上帝的天堂是为那些选择侍奉他的人准备的，但大地是属于最强者。他确信世上没有救赎，活着就是身处地狱，他将犯下各种各样的邪恶与残酷行径，好让他的名字响彻大地，甚至传到九霄云外。他就像《血色子午线》里的法官大人——对，《血色子午线》里的，或是萨德侯爵之流。我觉得他身上有一种意识形态化的虐恋狂倾向，如果这些记载可以相信的话。他们现在进入了奥里诺科河，河面
is widening, which is great news for them because it means that they're clearly approaching the Atlantic. It's really hot and humid in Venezuela in July, which is when they're there. And Aguirre is very hot-tempered. He says, we've got all these porters and guides with us, let us abandon them here. So they abandon them on the riverbank and they're crying and they're desperate. And there's nothing there. I mean, it's nothing there at all. Kind of dangerous animals and mudflats. And a couple of the Spaniards say, come on, this is a bit harsh. I mean, we've been traveling with these guys for months. And Aguirre says, right, you've got to go. And he has them garrotted or shot, people try to protest and then at last on the 1st of July 1561 they enter
越来越宽，这对他手下是个好消息，因为这意味着他们显然正在接近大西洋。委内瑞拉七月份的天气又热又潮湿，他们正是在这个时候到达的。阿吉雷脾气非常暴躁。他说，我们带着这么多的挑夫和向导，把他们全抛弃在这里吧。于是他们把这些人抛弃在河岸上，那些人痛哭流涕、绝望无助。而那里什么都没有。我是说，那里真的什么都没有。只有危险的动物和泥滩。几个西班牙人说，拜托，这有点太残酷了。我是说，我们跟这些人一起旅行了好几个月。阿吉雷说，好啊，那你们也得走。于是他下令把这些人绞死或枪决，还有人试图抗议。最后，在1561年7月1日，他们进入了
the Atlantic this incredible voyage they've covered 4,000 miles in nine months they've lost about half of the original party at this stage but they're still alive 17 days later they glimpse the island of Margarita when they see the island Aguirre says brilliant and he celebrates by grotting two more of his men who he thinks could conceivably betray him to the authorities when he gets there and then they sail to the island and he sends a messenger ashore to ask for help with the words we are ordinary sailors lost at sea. And presumably this is quite convincing because they must look an absolute
大西洋。这是一次不可思议的航行，他们在九个月内走了4000英里，在这个阶段他们大约损失了一半的初始随行人员，但他们依然活着。17天后，他们隐约看到了玛格丽塔岛。当他们看到这座岛时，阿吉雷说，太棒了！他通过绞死另外两个手下来庆祝，他认为这两个人到了地方后极有可能向当局背叛他。然后他们航行到岛上，他派了一个信使上岸请求帮助，用的说辞是“我们是迷失在海上的普通水手”。想必这个借口相当有说服力，因为他们经历了那一切之后，看起来肯定
mess after. Yeah. How long have they been in the jungle? Nine months. Nine months. They've been there nine months, they're emaciated, they're sodden, they're filthy. The governor completely believes this so he turns up with his officials, it's all very very friendly and Aguirre says, you know, would it be all right if we came on shore? Can we take some exercise and bring our weapons just to practice? And the governor says, yeah, great. So they march ashore as though they're kind of on parade. It's very well planned. And then they sort of unsheathed their swords and leveled their guns. And they take the governor and his officials hostage. So this is obviously not a huge place. You know, you're talking about hundreds of people rather than thousands. But because as we said at the beginning, the Spanish presence is quite thin, it's quite thinly spread. So they march into the main town of Margarita. They seize the fort, they
狼狈不堪。是的。他们在丛林里待了多久？九个月。九个月。他们在那里待了九个月，骨瘦如柴，浑身湿透，污秽不堪。总督完全相信了这番说辞，于是他和官员们一起赶了过来，一切都非常非常友好。阿吉雷说，你知道的，我们上岸可以吗？我们可以活动活动筋骨，带上武器只是为了练习一下吗？总督说，好啊，太棒了。于是他们列队上岸，就像在进行阅兵一样。这个计划策划得非常周密。接着他们突然拔出宝剑，举起火枪。他们把总督和他的官员们扣为人质。所以这显然不是个大地方。你知道的，这里说的是几百人而不是几千人。但正如我们在开头所说，西班牙人的存在感非常薄弱，分布得很稀疏。所以他们开进玛格丽塔的主城镇。他们占领了堡垒，
lock up the governor and all the other bigwigs. They break into the treasury, they steal all the gold that's been stored, ready to be shipped to Spain. They burn the account books, which to me is a sign that there is clearly some kind of serious political motive behind all this. It's not just kind of insane nihilism, because clearly this is an attack on the idea of authority and royal authority. And what I think we'll see runs through this is Aguirre and some of the others clearly have a deep resentment. He's already said if we capture El Dorado Philip II will take it from us and give it to aristocrats and viceroys and bureaucrats and of course that had you know for Cortes in Mexico when we did that episode that that series a couple
把总督和其他大人物都锁了起来。他们闯入国库，偷走了所有准备运往西班牙的黄金。他们烧毁了账簿，这在我看来清楚地表明，这一切背后显然有着某种严肃的政治动机。这绝不仅仅是疯狂的虚无主义，因为这显然是对权威和王权概念的攻击。我认为贯穿其中的一点是，阿吉雷和其他一些人显然怀有深深的怨恨。他之前就已经说过，如果我们夺取了黄金国，腓力二世就会把它从我们手中夺走，分给贵族、总督和官僚。当然了，对于几年前我们在那一季节目里讲过的科尔特斯在墨西哥的经历来说，这事其实就已经在他身上发生过了。他征服了一切，然后却被排挤出去，所以我想这些事一直留在他们的脑海里。我也在想，这其中是不是有一种巴斯克民族主义的成分？虽然用民族主义来形容可能有点时代错置，因为巴斯克人是骄傲的山地民族。我是说，这些人很多都来自西班牙的边缘地带，正如大家熟知的，科尔特斯和他在墨西哥的盟友中，很多人都来自埃斯特雷马杜拉，也就是那种边境地带。同样地，阿吉雷也来自边境地带。他不是来自大都市西班牙、卡斯蒂利亚，也不是来自某座伟大的城市。我觉得，对于皇家官员，
of years ago that had kind of happened to him. He'd conquered it all and then been sort of pushed out and so I think that's at the back of their mind. I wonder also is there a kind of element of Basque and nationalism would be anachronistic because the Basques are proud mountain people. I mean a lot of these people are from a kind of Spanish periphery so you know famously Cortes and his allies in Mexico a lot of them had come from Extremadura, the sort of borderlands. And again, Aguirre is from a borderland. He's not from metropolitan Spain, Castile, from, you know, one of the great cities. And I think there probably is
以及西班牙和卡斯蒂利亚式的权威，他们心里其实很可能积蓄了相当多的怨恨。正是如此。事实上，我们会看到，一会儿还会有更多的证据证明这一点。对他们来说一个巨大的问题是，有一位传教士正在玛格丽塔访问，他们在那里的时候正好在玛格丽塔停留，此人名叫蒙特西诺斯，是个来自圣多明哥的家伙。他有一艘大船，在混乱中乘船逃走了。这对阿吉雷来说是个坏消息。这真是个大坏消息，他逃到了大陆上，正是在这个时候，关于阿吉雷归来及其不端行为的消息开始在西班牙各殖民地传开。所以从这
a fair bit of resentment actually of kind of royal officials. But also Spanish, Castilian kind of authority. Exactly. And actually, we'll see, there'll be more proof of this in a second. One great problem for them is that a missionary is visiting Margarita, has stopped at Margarita while they're there, a man called Montesinos, a guy from Santo Domingo and he has a big ship and he gets away in this in the chaos. Bad news for Aguirre. It's very bad news, he goes off to the mainland and this is the point at which word of Aguirre's return and his kind of misconduct begins to spread across the Spanish colonies. So from this
个时候起，他失去了对他来说至关重要的出其不意的优势。我认为也就是在这个时候，我敢说他真的开始有点失控了。所以在此之前，尽管有那么多的绞刑，我觉得其中依然带有一点理性，但我们被告知，就在这个时候，他的一些手下试图叛逃，而他“狂怒不已，像疯子一样咆哮，气得口吐白沫”。他把他们抓起来绞死了，还把他们的尸体游街示众，并附上留言：“这些人被处决，是因为他们是卡斯蒂利亚国王的忠实臣民。”汤姆，这也许是你那个观点的又一个证据。
point onwards he has lost the element of surprise that I think was so important to him and I think this is the point at which dare I say he really does begin to lose the plot. So up to this point with all the garroting I think there has still been an element of rationality but we're told that at this point some of his men tried to defect and he was, quote, furious and raved like a madman, foaming at the mouth with rage and passion. He has them captured, he garrots them, their bodies are displayed with the message, these men were executed because they were faithful vassals of the King of Castile. Perhaps another bit of evidence for your point, Tom.
或者说，这体现了卡斯蒂利亚某种阶级代表性。汤姆，也许这是你那个观点的又一个证据。或者这可能也是某种阶级代表性的体现。我觉得这绝对带有一点阶级对抗的色彩，事实上，跳跃到20世纪来看，特别是某些拉丁美洲历史学家曾说过，这家伙才不是疯子，他是个阶级斗士，是个社会主义者，是个先锋派马克思主义者。好吧，如果根据目前的证据来看，这可能有点过头了。但他下令说，我们必须把所有的——我引述一下——“主教、总督、总统、审计长、总督、律师、诉讼代理人，以及出身高贵的卡巴列罗（骑士）”全部搜捕起来。换句话说，
Or of kind of class represent of Castile. Perhaps another bit of evidence for your point Tom. Or of kind of class representent perhaps. I think there definitely is a bit of class representent and actually sort of jumping ahead in the 20th century in particular some Latin American historians said this guy's not a madman he's a class warrior he's a socialist he is a Marxist avant la lettre. Right possibly going a little bit far is it based on the evidence so far. But he issues orders, he says we must round up all the, and I quote, bishops, viceroys, presidents, auditors, governors, lawyers and procurators, as well as the caballeros of noble blood. In other words,
就是绅士阶层。这些人一直在吸干印第安人的血。他所说的——他指的不是从当地土著居民那里搜刮，而是从我们这里搜刮。我们通过汗水和暴力赢得了这片土地和这些黄金，而这些财富却被那些舞文弄墨的官僚、精英阶层的建制派、毫无骨气的纨绔子弟给吸干了。我觉得这种情绪绝对是存在的。所以在这个时候，玛格丽塔陷入了一场恐怖统治。最富有的人被关起来，他们的钱财被盗，总督被绞死，他的官员们也被绞死。阿吉雷现在用一种不断强化的残酷手段进行统治。所以如果任何人对绞死某人犹豫不决，他就会把那个人也绞死。他说，你知道的，你们所有人都必须参与进来。现在发生了一个非常非常可怕的时刻。
the gentlemen. These people have been sucking the indies dry. What he, and he doesn't mean from the native inhabitants, he means from us. We have won, you know, through our sweat and our violence, we have won this land and this gold and it has been sucked from us by pen pushing bureaucrats, you know, elitist establishment types, chinless toffs. And I think that is definitely there. So at this point, there's a bit of a reign of terror in Margarita. The richest citizens are locked up, their money is stolen, the governor is garrotted and his officials are garrotted. Aguirre is now ruling with a kind of rotifier. So if anybody hesitates to garrot somebody he garrots them as well. He says you know if you've got to be in on this and now there's a really
我们在舞台上聊过这个，对吧？我以前总是非常喜欢故事的这一段。他听到一个谣言说皇家军队登陆了，这其实并不是真的，于是他出去迎战，留下他的首席副手——一个叫马丁·佩雷斯的人——负责看守堡垒。当他经历这次虚惊一场回来后，他手下的另一个人——他们整天都在内讧——告诉他，马丁·佩雷斯一直在密谋反对你，这根本不是真的。阿吉雷说，好啊，把他带进来。人被带进来了。阿吉雷的手下从家具后面什么的突然跳出来，用刀捅这个人，
really terrible moment. We talked about this on stage didn't we and I always used to really enjoy this part of the story. He hears a rumor that the royal troops have landed which is not true and he goes out to face them and he leaves his chief lieutenant who's a guy called Martin Perez in charge of the fort and when he gets back after this false alarm one of his other men they're all feuding the whole time one of his other men says Martin Perez has been plotting against you, which is not true. Aguirre says, right, bring him in. He comes in. Aguirre's men kind of leap out from behind the furniture or something and stab this man
还用火绳枪向他射击。但佩雷斯并没有死。他受了重伤。鲜血和内脏流得到处都是，他竟然像个弗兰克斯坦的怪物一样，踉踉跄跄地冲出房间。然后想象一下这座美丽的殖民地宅邸。手里捧着自己的肠子。木质栏杆留下了这些痕迹，他就像个怪物一样跌跌撞撞地走在走廊里。
and shoot him with an arquebus. But Perez is not killed. He's hideously wounded. Kind of blood and entrails are everywhere and he manages to, like a sort of Frankenstein's monster, he lurches out of the room. Then imagine this lovely colonial mansion. Holding in his guts. A wooden balustrade leaving this and he's like lurching like a monster down the corridor.
人们发出尖叫，惊恐万状地奔逃，阿吉雷的手下在后面追赶他。我不该笑的，这真是个可怕的场景。阿吉雷的手下在追赶他，依然试图刺他、射击他之类的。最后他们把他逼入了绝境，字面意义上的墙角，他们设法结果了他。他们割断了他的喉咙，场面惨不忍睹。我是说他的内脏流得到处都是。阿吉雷发现其中一个人脸色看起来显然有点发绿，对，
People screaming and running in terror and stuff and Aguirre's men are chasing him. I shouldn't laugh, it's a terrible scene. Aguirre's men are chasing him, still trying to stab him and shoot him and stuff and Eventually they corner him, I mean literally in a corner and they manage to finish him off They cut his throat and it's a terrible scene. I mean his entrails are everywhere Aguirre spots one of the men clearly looking a little bit green yeah, and this is a guy called Antonio Mosso who had been one of the murderers of Dona Ines and And this is a guy called Antonia Mosso who had been one of the murderers of Dona Ines and
这个人叫安东尼奥·莫索，他曾是杀害多娜·伊内斯的凶手之一。而这个人叫安东尼奥·莫索，曾是杀害多娜·伊内斯的凶手之一。
Aguirre says you don't look like you know, you don't seem to be enjoying this. Were you part of his conspiracy? Do you hold so lightly the love that I feel for you? And you're most so is terrified and he protests his innocence and Aguirre seems completely unmoved and he's gonna reaching for the garrote And you're most so drops to his knees by the disemboweled body of Martin Perez. He basically wants to prove his loyalty and he shouts, curse this traitor, I will drink his blood. And then as Frey Simón reports, putting his mouth over the wounds in the head with more than demoniac rage, he began to suck the blood and brains that issued from the wounds and swallowed what he sucked as if he were a famished dog.
阿吉雷对他说，你看起来——你知道的，你似乎并不享受这一切。你是他阴谋的同伙吗？你把我对你的爱看得如此轻贱吗？安东尼奥·莫索吓得魂飞魄散，他坚决否认并抗议自己的清白，而阿吉雷看起来完全无动于衷，他伸手去拿绞索。安东尼奥·莫索扑通一声跪倒在马丁·佩雷斯那被开膛破肚的尸体旁。他基本上是为了证明自己的忠诚，大喊道：诅咒这个叛徒，我要喝他的血！正如弗雷·西蒙所记载的那样，他把嘴贴在头部的伤口上，带着超乎寻常的恶魔般的狂怒，开始吮吸从伤口中涌出的血和脑浆，并像一只饥饿的狗一样把吸出的东西吞了下去。
And Aguirre says to him, oh, brilliant. You know, you and I are very much on the same page. You're clearly on the side of the angels. And so Yamoso has proved his loyalty, which is great. On the one hand, it seems so grotesque as to be an exaggeration. And on the other hand, so kind of revoltingly unspeakable that you'd think someone wouldn't make that up. They wouldn't make it up and it's a very detailed story. It's a very detailed story with names, kind of dates, places.
阿吉雷对他说，哦，太棒了。你知道的，你和我的想法完全一致。你显然是站在天使这一边的。于是约莫索证明了自己的忠诚，这很好。一方面，这 grotesque 得简直像是夸张。另一方面，又是如此令人作呕、难以言表，让人觉得编造不出这样的情节。他们不会编造出来的，而且这是一个非常详细的故事。这是一个细节丰富的古老故事，有着名字、日期、地点。
So it's so hard to tell what the truth of this is, but undoubtedly there is a lot of very genuine violence. And I don't think there's any doubt that they have gone, because he would often say to his men, if you're thinking now the King of Spain can take us back, you are greatly mistaken. We are in so deep now that we just have to keep going. Well that signature, the traitor, I mean that's really what kicks it off isn't it? It is. I mean he's not wrong. He recognised I think straight away there's no way back from this. When we're in we're all in. So now he decides right we're going to have to carry on with the rest of the plan. We'll cross to the mainland. He has an exciting new flag which he's had specially made, a pirate flag of course. It's black with red crossed swords on it. I mean honestly if you were
所以很难说这其中的真相到底是什么，但毫无疑问，其中夹杂着许多非常真实的暴力。而且毫无疑问，他们已经走上了不归路，因为他经常对手下说，如果你现在觉得西班牙国王还能接纳我们，那你就大错特错了。我们现在陷得太深，只能硬着头皮走下去了。那个署名“叛国者”，这才是真正点燃导火索的原因，对吧？确实如此。我的意思是，他说得没错。他大概立刻就意识到，这件事已经没有回头路了。既然上了贼船，我们就只能一条路走到黑。现在他决定，好吧，我们必须继续执行剩下的计划。我们要横渡到大陆。他有一面令人兴奋的新旗帜，那是他特意让人制作的，一面海贼旗，当然是黑底红双剑。老实说，如果你是
you were at some new world port and you saw a ship with that flag sailing towards you. You'd run a mile. I don't want to be having to either have my brains drunk by somebody or drinking somebody else's brains. No. I mean I wouldn't even drink your brains Tom to be frank. Oh I'm glad that's on the record. So they crossed to the mainland. It takes them eight days on the 7th of September, 1561. They arrive on the coast of what's now Venezuela and it's deserted. The word has spread that he's coming and the people have been told, evacuate the towns.
新大陆某个港口的人，看到一艘挂着那种旗帜的船向你驶来。你早就逃之夭夭了。我可不想落得个脑浆被别人喝掉或者去喝别人脑浆的下场。没错。说实话，汤姆，我连你的脑浆都不想喝。哦，我很高兴这句话被录下来了。于是他们渡海来到大陆。他们花了八天时间，在1561年9月7日，他们到达了现在委内瑞拉的海岸，那里空无一人。消息已经传开，说他要来，人们都被告知：疏散城镇。
We're sending troops that this mad man is on the loose. We'll sort this out. He burns his ships. A very kind of, you know, Alexander the greats, Alexander the greats detail. Exactly. He burns his ships and he says he orders, he's got heralds and he says, go and proclaim a war of fire and blood against the king of Castile and his vassals. He marches on this
我们正派军队过去，这个疯子在逍遥法外。我们会解决这事的。他烧掉了自己的船。一个非常具有亚历山大大帝风格的细节。没错。他烧毁了船只，并下令——他有传令兵，他说：去宣战，对卡斯蒂利亚国王及其臣民宣战，实行血火洗礼。他向这座城市进发。
town called Valencia and he's in a very sort of Mr Kurtz mode at this point. So he's been carried in a hammock. It's incredibly hot. He's got a fever. He's completely emaciated We're told by the sources He was reduced to a skeleton at the point of death and I suspect at this point some of his men are thinking I really hope he dies if there's some way we could get out of this, but he doesn't die Unfortunately recovers from the fever madder than ever you keep saying this that gets madder than ever Yeah, you don't think he was mad before? I think he's reached a certain level of madness a few pages back to be honest. I think he's reached a certain level of madness several minutes ago.
这座城市叫巴伦西亚，此时他完全处于库尔兹先生那样的状态。他被抬在吊床里，天气热得难以置信，还发着高烧，骨瘦如柴。资料显示他已经瘦得只剩一副骨架，濒临死亡。我猜当时他手下有些人心里一定在想：‘如果有什么办法能让我们活着离开这儿，我真希望他赶紧死。’但他偏偏没死。不幸的是，他从高烧中恢复过来后，变得比以前更加疯狂了。你一直这么说，他变得越来越疯狂了。是啊，难道你认为他以前不疯吗？说实话，我觉得几页纸之前他就已经达到了某种疯狂的程度。我觉得他在几分钟前就达到了某种疯狂的境界。
I think there's still some way to go, frankly. I mean the whole drinking the brain stuff. The drinking brains is poor, I agree with that. I think you have to be pretty mad to be madder than that. He let the Basque Country down there, I think Tom was about to say. So he celebrates his recovery by executing a man called Gonzalo and Gonzalo's crime is that he'd gone off without permission to catch some parrots. That's the laugh. I think at this point there's a lot of, there's a lot of great laughter, as parrot fancy as a...
坦白说，我觉得他还有一段路要走。我是说，喝脑浆那些事。喝脑浆这招太低级了，我同意这一点。我觉得你得疯到一定程度，才能比那更疯狂。汤姆刚才好像想说，他让巴斯克地区的人失望了。于是他通过处决一个叫贡萨洛的人来庆祝自己病愈，贡萨洛的罪名是未经许可私自跑去抓几只鹦鹉。这太荒谬了。我觉得此时此刻有各种各样精彩的笑声，把鹦鹉爱好者当作...
Slaughtered. Slaughtered around him. They get to Valencian and he writes this mad letter to Philip II, which many historians have written about this, say, is one of the maddest letters in Spanish history. Well, all history you might say. I mean, let's pick it up. It is properly mad. He says, King Philip, son of Charles the Invincible, I, Lope de Aguirre, thy vassal, am an old
被屠杀。在他周围遭到屠杀。他们到达巴伦西亚后，他写了一封疯狂的信给腓力二世，许多历史学家都写过这件事，称这是西班牙历史上最疯狂的信件之一。或者可以说，是所有历史中最疯狂的。来吧，我们来看看。这封信确实疯了。他说：‘国王腓力，无敌的查理之子，我，洛佩·德·阿吉雷，你的臣民，是一个老'
Christian of poor but noble parents of the town of Onyate in Biscay. Actually, an old Christian is an interesting line because it's a reminder that actually Spain was not entirely Christian until relatively recently. Yeah, so he's contrasting himself with the Jews and the Muslims who've converted. Exactly. So he's saying, I am of loyal, you know, Spanish stock. And he says, for 54 years I did the great service in Peru in the conquest of the Indians and I did all this in your name and I didn't ask your officers for payment, but you have been very cruel and ungrateful to me and my companions for such good service. Again, the hint of the political resentments that may lie behind this. We won these lands while you remained
基督徒，出身于比斯开奥尼亚特镇贫寒但高贵的父母。实际上，“老基督徒”这句很有意思，因为它提醒我们，直到相对晚近的时候，西班牙并非完全是基督教国家。是的，所以他将自己与那些皈依的犹太人和穆斯林进行对比。没错。所以他说，我是忠诚的西班牙血统。他说：‘在秘鲁征服印第安人的过程中，我为之效劳了五十四年，我以你的名义做了这一切，而且我没有向你的官员索取报酬，但是对于如此优异的服务，你对我以及我的同伴却非常残酷和忘恩负义。’这再次暗示了可能隐藏在背后的政治怨恨。我们在你留在
quietly in Spain. Remember, King Philip, that thou hast no right to draw revenues from these provinces since their conquest has been without danger to thee." Again, that point. He complains a lot about the cruelties which thy judges and governors exercise in thy name, the oppression of thy ministers, who give places to their nephews and their children, who dispose of our lives, our reputations and our fortunes. So, you know, there are all these kind of nepo babies coming over here and taking the big jobs. Also in a very 16th century theme, resentment of the religious orders, the corruption of the morals of the monks is so great. They tell you that they're converting Indians, but actually they are enemies of the poor, they're avaricious, gluttonous and proud.
西班牙享受安逸的同时赢得了这些土地。记住，国王腓力，你没有权利从这些省份征收税赋，因为它们的征服对你而言没有任何危险。’又是这句话。他抱怨了许多你的法官和总督以你的名义行使的残暴行径，抱怨你的大臣们的压迫，他们把职位分给自己的侄子和孩子，随意处置我们的生命、声誉和财富。所以，你知道，所有这些裙带关系的小家伙们都跑到这里来占据要职。还有一个非常十六世纪的主题，那就是对宗教修会的不满，僧侣们道德腐败得如此厉害。他们告诉你他们在感化印第安人，但实际上他们是穷人的敌人，贪婪、饕餮而又傲慢。
The poor, by that he's again not speaking about the Indians, he's speaking about Aguirre and his compadres. Yes, exactly. And then there's an ending which I very much enjoy. Because the great thing about this is he lurches from one thought to another in the same sentence. So he says, my comrades and I pray to God that thy strength may ever be increased against the Turk and the Frenchman and all others who desire to make war against thee. But because of thy ingratitude, I am a rebel against thee until death, signed Lope de Guerre, the wanderer. So as John Hemings says, an extraordinary document,
关于穷人，他指的又不是印第安人，而是阿吉雷和他的死党们。是的，完全正确。然后是一个我非常喜欢的结尾。因为最棒的一点是，他在同一个句子中从一个想法跳跃到另一个想法。所以他说：‘我的战友们和我祈求上帝，愿你的力量永远增长，以抵御土耳其人、法国人以及所有其他想要对你发动战争的人。但由于你的忘恩负义，我将与你为敌直到死去，署名：流浪者洛佩·德·阿吉雷。’正如约翰·海明斯所说，这是一份非同寻常的文件，
a mixture of rebellious defiance, megalomania, and self-pity. Robert Silverberg says, few kings had ever received such a message from a subject, shifting kind of attitudes within the space of sometimes the same sentence and the tragedy is Philip the second probably never even got to read it because there's no evidence that you did read it must have
融合了叛逆的挑衅、自大狂和自怜。罗伯特·西尔维伯格说，很少有国王收到过臣民这样的信件，在有时甚至同一个句子的篇幅内，态度发生转变，而悲剧在于，腓力二世可能根本没机会读到它，因为没有任何证据表明他读过，这封信一定
been intercepted by a royal official and who filed it under M for mad I mean to be fair to Philip though I mean he does love reading a letter that's basically all he's doing isn't it yeah he's sitting in a very gloomy in LS Corial yeah this would have livened up his day I think. Just endless stuff about tax returns and things. Exactly. And then suddenly you get that. Let's get to the end of the story. Aguirre ends up cornered in this town called Barquise Meadow in Venezuela. A lot of his men have deserted. There's an awful lot of foaming at the mouth. There's a very famous incident while he's marching into Barquise Meadow. It's pouring with rain and their horses are slipping and sliding in the mud.
被某个皇家官员截获了，并被归档在M开头的‘疯子’（Mad）文件夹里。不过说句公道话，对于腓力来说，他其实很喜欢读信，基本上他整天也就干这个，不是吗？是的，他坐在埃斯科里亚尔宫阴暗的房间里。是的，这封信大概能让他的日子生动一些。到处都是没完没了的关于纳税申报单之类的事情。没错。然后突然间你就收到了这个。让我们讲到故事的结局。阿吉雷最终被逼得走投无路，困在委内瑞拉一个叫巴基西梅托的小镇上。他的许多手下都开小差了。到处都是气急败坏的咒骂。当他开拔进入巴基西梅托时，发生了一件非常著名的事件。当时下着倾盆大雨，他们的马在泥地里滑来滑去。
He shakes his fist at the heavens and he shouts, Does God think that because it rains in Torrance I am not going to reach Peru and destroy the world? Then he does not know me. Brilliant. I compared him to a Shakespeare hero, but actually he's now turning into a kind of Marlowe hero. He totally is, isn't he? So he gets to Bar is he metto? They're surrounded by royalist troops outside the town. I mean they are literally Tom They're literally eating the dogs. They're like the people of Springfield, Pennsylvania
他向着天空挥舞着拳头大喊：‘上帝难道以为，因为托兰斯下雨，我就到不了秘鲁、毁灭不了世界吗？那他就不了解我了。’太精彩了。我把他比作莎士比亚剧中的英雄，但实际上他现在正在变成一个类似马洛剧中的英雄。完全是这样，不是吗？所以他到了巴基西梅托？他们被镇外的保皇派军队包围了。汤姆，他们真的是，他们真的在吃狗肉。他们就像宾夕法尼亚州斯普林菲尔德的居民一样。
Supposedly the local governor issues promises an amnesty to a gear ace men So some of them start to slip away. He says, the time has come, I think we should garrot some more of my men, the sick and the unwilling, let's have a little purge, we'll be leaner, more efficient at it. And even his lieutenants, his loyalists say to him, oh come on, that's going too far. What about the bloke who drank the blood? The bloke who drank the blood actually stays there. Well, you will see, he literally is the last person with him. So actually the drinking of the blood. The bloke who drank the blood actually stays there. Well you'll see he literally is the last person with him. So actually the drinking of the blood. Yeah it was a genuine sacrament. Yeah it
据说当地总督向阿吉雷的手下承诺了大赦，于是有些人开始溜走。他说：‘时机已到，我觉得我们应该再绞死几个我的人，那些生病的和不愿出力的人，让我们来一次小清洗，这样我们会更精干、更有效率。’甚至连他的副官、他的忠诚追随者都对他说：‘噢，拜托，这太过分了。那喝血的那家伙呢？’那个喝血的家伙实际上留在那儿了。好吧，你会看到，他真的是最后一个留在他身边的人。所以实际上，喝血的那家伙……那个喝血的家伙实际上留在那儿了。好吧，你会看到，他真的是最后一个留在他身边的人。所以实际上，喝血的……是的，这是一场真正的圣礼。是的，它
kind of was. Aguirre has a massive meltdown in middle of October. He summons all his men, what remain of them. He puts a dagger to his chest. He says why don't you cut out my heart. He says I have killed a lot of people but I quote I want you to understand that I did it in order to protect your lives and for the benefit of all. It's real kind of self pity here. This does not unfortunately impress them, so most of them defect. And on the morning of Monday the 27th of October 1561, those who are left say, could we please go out and make a last stand against the royalist army.
十月中旬，阿吉雷彻底精神崩溃了。他召集了所有剩下的人。他把一把匕首抵在自己的胸口。他说，你们为什么不挖出我的心呢。他说，我杀了很多但我要引用他的话，我想让你们明白我这么做是为了保护你们的生命，为了大家的利益。这里充满了真正的自怜。遗憾的是，这并没有打动他们，所以大部分人都叛变了。在1561年10月27日星期一的早晨，剩下的人说，我们能出去跟保皇派军队做最后的一搏吗？
He says fine. They go out of the town and as soon as they get out of the town they kind of drop their weapons and start shouting, Long live the king, god save the king. And they defect as well. Aguirre is gutted by this. The only person who's left is this, Yamoso, the blood and brains man. And Aguirre says, why are you still here? You know, why haven't you left me? And Yamoso says, so moving, he says, we were friends in life. I will live or die with you. And Aguirre, we we're told made no reply
他说，好。他们走出了城镇，一出城镇，他们就扔下武器，开始大喊：‘国王万岁，上帝保佑国王。’他们也叛变了。阿吉雷对此感到痛心疾首。唯一留下来的是这个叫亚莫索的家伙，也就是那个喝血吃脑的人。阿吉雷问：‘你为什么还在这儿？你知道的，你为什么不离开我？’亚莫索说，太感人了，他说：‘我们生前是朋友，我将与你同生共死。’而我们被告知，阿吉雷没有回答。
He was crestfallen and lost So that I think is lovely What follows? lesser Aguirre goes to his room and he gets at his arquebus is gone and he goes to find someone we haven't mentioned Elvira who has been there the whole time age was she now 14 God she must be so embarrassed Yeah, that's add as he's really let her down And he goes in and he says to her
他垂头丧气，不知所措。所以我觉得这很感人。接下来呢？悲伤的阿吉雷回到房间，发现火绳枪不见了，于是他去找一个我们还没提到的人——埃尔维拉，她一直都在那儿。她当时多大了？14岁。天哪，她一定尴尬极了。是的，因为他真的让她失望了。他走进去对她说：
My daughter my love. I thought I should see you married and a great lady But my sins and my great pride have wielded otherwise Commend yourself to God my daughter and make your peace with him for I can't bear that you would be called the daughter of a traitor." And that's quite moving. Perhaps a little more prosaic is he then also says, I don't want you to become a mattress for the unworthy, which, you know, you know what that means. Yes, of course. Elvira is extremely disturbed by this, falls to her knees and starts pleading. She says, Father, Father, Satan is misleading you. And she's got a maid called Juana who manages to wrestle the gun from his hands. But then he really lets himself, Elvira and the Basque Country down because he pulls out
‘我的女儿，我的爱人。我本想看你出嫁，成为一位伟大的夫人，但我的罪孽和我的傲慢导致了截然不同的结局。将你自己交托给上帝吧，我的女儿，与他和解，因为我无法忍受你被称为叛徒的女儿。’这相当感人。也许更朴实的是，他接着还说：‘我不想让你成为无能之辈的床垫。’你知道这意味着什么。是的，当然。埃尔维拉对此感到极其不安，双膝跪地开始恳求。她说：‘父亲，父亲，是撒旦在误导你。’她有一个叫胡安娜的女仆，设法从他手中抢下了枪。但随后他真的让他自己、埃尔维拉以及巴斯克地区失望了，因为他拔出
a dagger and stabs Elvira through the heart. Stabs his daughter. Yeah, kills his daughter. There's a twist. I thought that he was going to kill himself. No. Well, you would think it would be a more satisfying story in a way if you now turned the dagger on himself but he doesn't actually happens is moments later royal troops burst into the apartment again picks up the arquebus again but he's shaking so much that he can't fire it he person to tears. After all that yes soft heart after all the soldiers lead him outside there is talk of a trial but actually.
了一把匕首，刺穿了埃尔维拉的心脏。刺死了他的女儿。是的，杀了他的女儿。这真是一个反转。我以为他要自杀呢。没有。好吧，你本来会觉得，如果他把匕首转向自己，故事会更圆满一些，但他没有。实际发生的是，片刻之后，皇家军队冲进了公寓。他再次拿起了火绳枪，但他颤抖得太厉害，根本无法开枪，他泪流满面。经历了这一切，是的，经历了这一切，他内心其实很柔软。士兵们把他带到外面，有人谈到了审判，但实际上……
Soldiers lead him outside there was talk of a trial but actually His important thing loads of his old cronies who defected are there and they say oh no, no trial no trial We should just kill him straight away because they they want the truth because of course they don't want the truth to come out of Their own complicity and two of his old gunners Volunteer to do it you talked about Shakespeare or sort of from Jacobean drama or something So in true Jacobean drama style the first shot doesn't quite kill him, but he's still able to talk, and he says, that has done the business, even though it hasn't. So then they have to shoot him again. He's now dead. They cut off his head and they put it in an iron cage. They cut off his hands. They wanted to send his hands on a kind of
士兵把他带到外面，有人谈到了审判，但实际上他最重要的事情是，他那些叛变的老死党都在那里，他们说：‘噢，不，不要审判，不要审判，我们应该马上杀了他。’因为他们想要真相，当然是因为他们不想让自己的共谋败露。他手下的两个老炮手自愿去执行。你刚才谈到莎士比亚或某种雅各宾时期的戏剧之类的。所以，在纯正的雅各宾戏剧风格中，第一枪并没有彻底杀死他，但他仍然能够说话，他说：‘这下大功告成了。’尽管其实并没有。所以他们不得不再次开枪。他现在死了。他们割下他的头，把它装在一个铁笼子里。他们割下了他的双手。他们想把他的双手送去进行某种
tour. So they sent his hands to the towns of Merida and Valencia, but the soldiers got bored of carrying them. One of the hands ended up being thrown in a river, and the other one was thrown to the dogs to eat. So that's payback for his men eating all the dogs. Yes, I suppose so. So the dogs have had the last laugh, which is nice. They have, yeah.
巡游。因此，他们把他的双手送到了梅里达和巴伦西亚镇，但士兵们厌倦了随身携带它们。其中一只手最后被扔进了一条河里，另一只手则被扔给狗吃了。这就是对他手下吃掉所有狗的报应。是的，我想是的。所以狗笑到了最后，这挺好的。确实是的。
So that's the end of Lope de Aguirre, and I guess the question, very briefly at the end, is what it actually means. Does it have to mean anything? I think it does. I like a bit of a meaning. Do you not like a meaning, Talmad? love a meaning what that this is very out of character It's just the random madness, but maybe it isn't you see so for some people so I guess for Werner Herzog in that film It's not random madness
这就是洛佩·德·阿吉雷的结局，我想这个问题，在最后简短地谈谈，就是它到底意味着什么。它一定要有什么意义吗？我觉得有的。我喜欢带点意义的东西。你难道不喜欢意义吗，托姆？我最喜欢意义了。这太不符合他的性格了。这只是随机的疯狂，但也许并非如此，你看。所以对有些人来说——我想对沃纳·赫尔佐格在那部电影里的看法来说，这不是随机的疯狂。
You could say it's Joseph Conrad style heart of darkness you go into the heart of the jungle your complicity in colonialism Leads you into evil. I mean, that's how some people have interpreted the story. Alternative explanation, of course, is that it's rather like Mr. Kurtz. It's about the human condition and it's about, you know, we've all got a Lope de Aguirre, a brain-sucking, daughter-murdering madman inside us, whether we like it or not. And that's actually how most historians, they have said he represents human evil in its purest form. Or there's the he's a revolutionary. Well that's I think the more interesting explanation and there's a very recent book by an American writer called Evan Balkan. I think it was his PhD
你可以说这是约瑟夫·康拉德式的《黑暗的心》，你深入丛林的核心，你在殖民主义中的共谋将你引向邪恶。我的意思是，有些人就是这样解读这个故事的。另一种解释当然是，这很像库尔兹先生。这是关于人类的境况，关于——你知道的，我们每个人内心深处都有一个洛佩·德·阿吉雷，一个吸脑浆、杀女儿的疯子，不管我们愿不愿意。实际上，大多数历史学家正是这样看的，他们说他代表了最纯粹形式的人类邪恶。或者还有一种说法，他是革命者。嗯，我觉得这更有趣，美国作家埃文·博尔肯最近出了一本书。我想那是他的博士论文
called Wrath of God and he argues he was the first revolutionary. I mean South America has loads of revolutionaries Che Guevara most famously. He argues that Aguirre makes sense politically, that you put him into the context of mid-century Spanish America, very flimsy colonial control, endless feuds, endless revolts, huge resentment of royal authority and Balkan points out all the accounts we have of him are from people who were complicit in the revolt and what they needed to do afterwards was to convince the Spanish authorities that it hadn't been political, that they had been coerced by a uniquely demented and demonic leader.
题为《上帝之怒》，他认为他是第一个革命者。南美洲有大量的革命者，最著名的就是切·格瓦拉。他认为阿吉雷在政治上是说得通的，如果你把他放在世纪中叶西班牙美洲的背景下——那里有非常脆弱的殖民控制、无休止的世仇、无休止的起义、对王权的巨大怨恨——博尔肯指出，我们拥有的关于他的所有记录都来自于那些参与叛乱的人，他们事后需要做的是说服西班牙当局，这并非出于政治动机，而是他们被一个独一无二的精神失常且恶魔般的领袖所胁迫。
Well, the demonic presumably, because then it would explain how they had been seduced, that effectively they've been the victims of witchcraft. Exactly. That Aguirre represents, that's why that point, the thing about, oh, he doesn't want to go to heaven, he's determined to throw himself into this kind of sardine pursuit of all that is cruel and brutal and all of this that's why I think that's very important to them to make that point to say there was no political context to this at all it was an exercise in pure demonic evil by a madman but there clearly was a political context it's the signing his name as a traitor that kicks off the whole well well, I mean, it's a coup, isn't it? It's an attempted coup.
嗯，恶魔般的大概是因为这样就能解释他们是如何被诱惑的，实际上他们成了巫术的受害者。没错。阿吉雷所代表的正是这一点，这就是为什么那个观点——关于他不想上天堂，他决心投身于对所有残忍和野蛮事物的狂热追求中——这就是为什么我认为这对于他们来说非常重要，去阐明这一点，说这里面根本没有政治背景，这是一个疯子纯粹的恶魔般邪恶的发泄。但显然是有政治背景的，他以叛徒身份签署名字，这才是引发整个事件的……嗯，我的意思是，这是一场政变，不是吗？这是一场未遂政变。
It is. And as Evan Balkan says in his book, Latin American history is a saga of rebels and populists and strongmen who appeal to the common man against overweening royal or state authority. You know, Simon Bolivar or whoever it might, or Juan Perón or whoever it might be. Hugo Chávez in Venezuela, the country with which Aguirre is most closely associated. So Hugo Chávez's culture ministry, I read in Evan Bolton's book, I think, had a section on its official website praising Aguirre as a quote, soldier, traitor, pilgrim, father, lover, dreamer. I think Father is probably an ironic one there. I mean you could say that he kills her to preserve her honour and say that she, you know, her fate is worse than death. I mean I guess that's how you could frame it. I mean
确实如此。正如埃文·博尔肯在他的书中所说，拉丁美洲的历史是一部叛逆者、民粹主义者和强人的传奇，他们呼吁普通人反对过分膨胀的王权或国家权威。你知道的，西蒙·玻利瓦尔或者其他任何人，或者胡安·庇隆或者其他任何人。委内瑞拉的乌戈·查韦斯，这个与阿吉雷联系最紧密的国家。所以我读到埃文·博尔肯的书时发现，乌戈·查韦斯的文化部在其官方网站上有一个板块，赞美阿吉雷是一个‘士兵、叛徒、朝圣者、父亲、恋人、梦想家’。我想‘父亲’这个词在那里大概带点讽刺意味吧。我的意思是，你可以说他杀她是为了维护她的荣誉，说她的命运比死还惨。我想这就是你可以构建它的方式。我的意思是，
that's how he's casting it. And there is clearly a very magical realist quality to the whole story. There definitely is a magical realist and maybe this would be our last closing point. The most famous of all European travellers who went to Latin America was Alexander Humboldt, German. He went to Venezuela in 1799 and he reported that the locals there said to him that at night strange ghostly fires danced over the plains. He wrote, This fire, like the willow, the wisp of our marshes, does not burn the grass. The people call these reddish flames the soul of the traitor Aguirre, and the
这就是他给自己的定性。而且整个故事显然具有非常魔幻现实主义的特质。确实有魔幻现实主义的色彩，也许这就是我们最后的结束语。到拉丁美洲去的欧洲旅行者中最著名的要数德国人亚历山大·冯·洪堡。他在1799年去了委内瑞拉，他报道说当地人告诉他，夜里奇异的幽灵之火在平原上跳跃。他写道：‘这种火，就像我们沼泽地的鬼火一样，不烧草。人们称这些红色的火焰为叛徒阿吉雷的灵魂，而',
natives believe that the soul of the traitor wanders in the savannas like a flame that flies the approach of men. Well Dominic, what an eerie note on which to end and what a week it's been. We've had angelic voices and we have had the fires of demons. And in a sense, we will be having both next week because we are back with season three of the French Revolution. And of course, Tom, members of the Rest is History Club will get all four episodes of that series on Monday.
当地人相信，叛徒的灵魂在稀树草原上游荡，就像一团逃避人类靠近的火焰。好了，多米尼克，这是一个多么诡异的结束音，这又是多么不可思议的一周。我们听到了天使般的声音，也见证了恶魔之火。从某种意义上说，我们下周将两者兼得，因为我们将带着法国大革命第三季回归。当然了，托姆，“历史余韵”俱乐部的会员们周一就能看到该系列的所有四集。
And if you want to join them, you merely have to sign up at therestishistory.com. Adios. Very exciting. That's the way I go. Goodbye. of that series on Monday. And if you want to join them, you merely have to sign up at therestishistory.com. Adios. Very exciting. That's the way to go. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想加入他们，只需在therestishistory.com注册即可。再见。太激动人心了。就这么办。再见。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。